So, auf geht's, in your face, Bastion alter, oh man sieht das Stream heute besser aus als
sonst nicht, ich glaub das ist einfach vorbei, lol, in der Vorschau sieht das richtig gut
aus, guck mal der Ehex ist auch da, so ich muss jetzt erstmal zum Fabian wieder in Discord
und ich muss dem Discord jetzt erstmal beibringen Push to Talk zu machen, weil sonst labern wir
uns die ganze Zeit irgendwie gegenseitig rein, das ist dann auch übelst fail, und mein Chat
geht nicht, doch jetzt funktioniert er, Leute, ich bin wieder da, Leute sag mir mal wie das
von der Lautstärke ist mit Fabian, ob das so passt, also jetzt mein Stream, oh das wird
verwirrend sag ich dir, naja wenn ich in mein Chat gucke und da was erzähle und du in dein
Chat guckst und da was erzählst dann blickt keiner mehr durch, ja das ist halt immer wieder
kacke, das checkt dann keiner mehr, ich muss jetzt dein Chat auch nochmal aufmachen, Chat
overkill, null, ich gucke mal dass ich mich zumindest muten kann, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
großartige Erzählstellaktionen mache, eigentlich können wir auch jetzt Klai zum Spot geben
fällt mir gerade ein, weil ich bin in Altinova mit dem Wizarders, ich bin quasi gleich da,
ich muss halt spätestens dann wenn ich volle Energie habe, aber das ist jetzt nicht so,
das regt ja jetzt nicht so schnell, ich glaube die Lautstärke ist gut, wir müssen ungefähr
gleich laut sein, passt, erstmal gucken wie ich mich muten kann, ah jetzt bin ich gemutet,
sehr schön, kannst du mich jetzt carryen, ja ich mach Wizard.ie, easy, ich lock aber
näher auf irgendeinen Twink, ich bleib auf meinem Ranger, achso warte mal, lass mich
aber noch ganz kurz 700 von den Dingern sammeln, ich bin jetzt, ja mach ich reite, dann kann
ich das nämlich abgeben und muss den ganzen Schrott mit schleppen, ach ich muss Pets
feeden, gleich nochmal umloggen, was meinst du, ich denke ohne YouTube wäre Cod nie so
explodiert, Alter jetzt immer wieder bei Cod Digger, kaum ist dein Stream an, eigentlich
wollte ich mich muten, dass du das gar nicht mitkriegst, echt, ja, das geht, ja ich hab
jetzt extra im Discord Mute Button, aber irgendwie hat es nicht funktioniert, jetzt, jetzt hat
es funktioniert, jetzt war ich gemutet, ich glaube ich war vorher gemutet, wo ich mit
dir geredet habe, du hast mich gar nicht gehört, achso, nee ich war concentrated, weil ich
wissen wollte wer hier rumschreit, nee nee ich hab mich vorher gemutet und jetzt entmuted,
oh das ist übelst mir, jetzt blicke ich den mal durch, also jetzt mute ich mich mal wenn
ich erzählstelles mache, ja, am besten wäre es wenn ich uns beide muten könnte mit einer
Taste, das muss ich jetzt mal angucken, jetzt wird es kompliziert, advanced streaming tactics,
Leute weißt jemand wie man in Discord einen Button einrichten kann um quasi alles zu muten,
das muss, muss doch gehen, alter dieses, äh,
ich kann deinen Chat aber nicht noch aufmachen Max, nee nee nee das nicht, ich bin auch übelst
verwirrt, geht nie, jetzt kannst du nie machen, da ist ja absolut der Gehirntod instant, ja,
ist echt so, oder noch spielen dabei, äh, no, seems good, ich muss jetzt erstmal in
Discord hier, ich mute mich mal kurz, was ist denn bei Red Battlefield 3, erzähl mal,
so jetzt muss ich doch gucken wie ich den Fabian auf Hotkey muten kann, ich finde die
letzten Tage ging es wieder, hier, Lautsprecher ein aus, Hotkey, kann ich den gleichen, den
gleichen Hotkey für muten und end muten nehmen, so, nice das funktioniert, ok, ready, naja
aber jetzt funktioniert muten und end muten nicht mehr, Discord, ich krieg die Krise,
irgendjemand hat gerade gefragt ob ich der Meinung bin, dass Cod genauso abgehoben wäre
ohne YouTube, wie es halt ist, bzw. ob Cod genauso erfolgreich geworden wäre ohne YouTube,
ich denke nicht, also vor allem so im Jahr 2000, sagen wir so ab 2010, wo das so richtig
abging, ähm, hat das finde ich einen großen Teil dazu beigetragen, dann muss ich eh noch
mal schnell nach Altinora reiten, fällt mir gerade ein, so also muten dich und mich funktioniert
jetzt, ich hab's hingekriegt, easy, nice, GG Eats, easy clap sagt man heutzutage, easy clap,
GG Eats ist er aus, easy clap sagt man heute, weiss nicht warum, weiss nicht, hat das alles
immer nen Sinn, was man macht, eigentlich schon, weil easy clap würde dann bedeuten
dass man halt jemanden beipflichtet, easy clap, ja aber heute ist alles wenn man game gewonnen
hat und sowas war das easy, ne das macht der Chat, der Chat macht der easy clap, wenn was
easy war, so als müsste ich gemutet sein, nö, btf, lul, jetzt hat's funktioniert nur
wenn ich in Discord drin bin, alter ich hab schon wieder keinen Bock mehr auf das Gefrickel,
so, funkydome, max, danke für das Meltdown Video, das ist das einzige Video das das Thema
gut verständlich erklärt, also auch wenn man immer sagt Eigenlob stinkt und sowas,
aber ich find auch wenn ich mir die anderen Videos eingeguckt hab, die haben einfach
mehr oder weniger das wiedergegeben, was auf irgendwelchen News Seiten drauf steht, und
da wird man halt nicht wirklich schlaut raus, ne, dann, und am besten find ich die Leute,
die dann erzählt haben, hm, max, also das ist total falsch was du da erzählst, das
ist nicht, bitte, oder der eine, der eine Typ war geil unter dem Video, ne, er hat irgend
so ein Typ geschrieben, oh ha, oh ha, max, da musst du dich aber nochmal richtig informieren,
ist das nicht korrekt, hab ich gefragt, ja, ok, was stimmt denn nicht, hat er gemeint,
hm, schau dir doch das Video von Semper Video an, der erklärt es ganz gut, hab ich auch
gedacht, so, erst mal hier auf dicke Hose machen, so nach dem Motto, ich hab, ne, du
bist übelscheiß, hast keine Ahnung, weißt nicht was du erzählst, aber auf die Nachfrage
hin, ja, was jetzt eigentlich das Problem ist, na, keine Ahnung, also sind sie halt,
so, ich glaub du kriegst es gar nicht mit, wenn ich mich mute, oder, ne, also falls du,
also falls du, also ok, falls du mal was sagst und ich nicht antworte, hab ich mich vielleicht
gemuted, weil ich grad am labern bin, ja, so, Leute, jetzt gehts los, ich lock jetzt
gleich mal wizard um, dann geh ich mit Fabian zusammen ein bisschen, 1000 grind machen,
also nicht den billigen 1000 spot, sondern der, der schwierigere 1000 spot, der pro 1000
spot, so, und wenn man jetzt BDO noch beibringen könnte, das discord overlay anzumachen, wär
noch besser, aber irgendwie hat da, hat da BDO kein bock drauf auf discord overlay, weil
ich glaub ich kann mich halt nur muten, wenn ich, wenn ich quasi im discord bin, das ist
übelst kacke, so, kratzen ist es auf twitch nicht erlaubt zu streamen, tja, aber man darf
kratzen streamen, mittlerweile darfst du auf twitch doch alle streamen, heise geht sowieso
immer mehr den bach runter, ich find das ist eigentlich immer noch die beste news-seite
in der richtung, also auf deutsch, aber am besten allgemein muss ich sagen ist reddit
für solche sachen, da die passenden subreddits angucken, schaust du kein overwatch league
doch, mach ich, ich hab, ja vorgestern konnte ich nicht gucken, weil ich mein ich muss arbeiten
gehen, das hat natürlich nicht funktioniert, farbi an welcher channel bist du, oder willst
du mir das discord besser schaunen, ich bin aktuell wlea4, wir müssen dann halt mal gucken
wo frei ist, ich bin media 3, da ist golden bell am start, lull, lull, guck einfach mal,
wir gucken ja einfach mal am spot, würd ich sagen, ja, ich lauf mal hoch, ja, schulds,
müssen wir erstmal ein paar tränke noch preparen, zu schulds, schulds, kennst du als wizard
natürlich nie, was, tränke preparen, ne, ne, wozu, overrated, outdated, debated sind tränke
von wizard, brauchst net, das einzigen tränke ist, wenn irgendwann mal einer attackt, dann
hau ich halt hp potions rein, das reicht, mehr brauchste nicht, hp potions spam, da
ich ihn nicht so zeigen kann bekommst du halt den 5er kappa, so kyo, danke, ang stream carried,
flash carried, oder max wieder bdo am start, danke dir für die 5 euro, willkommen in der
frizzy army, da brauchste aber noch, da brauchste aber noch irgendeinen besseren spruch für,
würde man so als sellout streamer jetzt sagen, da brauchste, da brauchste aber noch irgendwie
was abgedrehtes, abgedrehteres, ja, frizzy army das ist einfach zu 0a15, das muss irgendwie
sein, keine ahnung was, was könnte man da machen, das die meisten sachen sind so richtig,
weißt du was die düngste army ist, ne, ich find von unge die raupen army, das ist so
dumm, die raupen army hat aber style, ich find das so bescheuert, also lass mal bitte
die raupen army in ruhe, weil raupen so furchtbar gefährliche army sind wahrscheinlich, jetzt
kommen gleich die fanboys, max, das kannst du nicht sagen, oh mein gott, die raupen army,
ich mut mich da mal kurz, so chat, was hab ich überlesen, wie kann es sein, dass in 2
jahren 2 grafikkarten von mir defekt geworden sind, kann es an der dauerbelastung liegen,
da ich jedoch fast jeden tag spiele, ne, also normalerweise ist, ganz ehrlich die meister
hardware geht nicht kaputt, vor allem nicht von normaler benutzung, du kriegst auch keine
cpu, selbst wenn du die übertaktest im normalen rahmen, kriegst du die nicht davon kaputt
und vom normalen spielen kriegst du, kriegst du ne grafikkarte auch nicht kaputt, ich meine
die ist dafür da, ich glaube mir ist noch nie im leben ne cpu oder ne grafikkarte durchgebrannt,
oh nie, warum hab ich eigentlich mein pferd nicht mitgenommen, ich bin zu dumm, eh, ich
bin farbe anfragen, jetzt brauch ich eigentlich nen pferdewagen oder so, wüsste ich nicht,
ne oder, jetzt reicht es wenn ich meinen gaul mitnehme, naja kommt halt drauf an, wir machen
auf jeden fall sellout loot, klein markplatz, jaja das ist auf jeden fall, so und den rest
wüsste ich nicht ob du zurecht, ich hab maids, ich komm zurecht, jetzt sag mal, haben wir
nicht für mich mal ne maid aus daily rewards abgeholt, irgendwann, weiß es nicht, es gab
doch eine umsonst, die hast du glaube ich abgeholt, wo sieht man das, dass die gibt?
eh, in der postbox war das glaube ich oder, in der post, das 200 und dann, ne ich hab
es auf uns genau anders rumgemacht boss orange, deshalb check ich es halt ne, warum, ich hab
es ja auch vorher so, ich bin übelst, leute ich bin mega überfordert muss ich euch sagen,
ich bin total, ich muss grad chat gucken, dann mich muten im discord, dann dass ich
den fabian nicht reinlabert, das ist übelst verwirrend, das ich blicke nimmer durch gerade,
das muss ich anders machen, also wenn wir jetzt am spot sind klein, ich bin jetzt bei
xp dran ne, also wenn wir gleich am spot sind, dann mach ich hier keine großartige mute action
mehr, aber ich guck immer noch chat, aber das ist zu viel, das krieg ich nicht gebacken,
ich weiß ja nichtmal wo ich mein pferd überhaupt abgestellt hab, wo hab ich mein pferd überhaupt
abgestellt, geh jetzt zum stable und hol den gaul wieder, mega verwirrung, jeder kriegt
ne gratis haschnitz voll, das wär gar nicht so schlecht als spruch, ich muss aber was
besseres geben, freeze army, das reicht nicht, moment, ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich mal
den pferdnix im rucksack hab, so jetzt reiten wir mal hier hoch, doch der hatte bock, sonst
hat er kein video gemacht, das ist halt seine art zu sprechen in videos, so wie das, der
hört sich doch in seinen videos genauso an wie in dem video was wir zusammen aufgenommen
haben, da waren aber auch die leute wieder geil, bei mir haben die leute erzählt so nach
dem motto er hat keine ahnung und bei ihm auf dem channel haben die leute erzählt, ich
hab keine ahnung, typisch youtube blödsinn, max wann kann man bei dir endlich sagen, dass
ich mich noch nicht darum gekümmert hab, bdo ist übelst fail, man kann in bdo noch nicht
mal das discord overlay aufmachen, muss ich mal danach suchen, bdo discord overlay, in
bdo funktioniert alles nicht richtig, weil das blöde ist, ich krieg auch die hotkeys
halt nicht im discord hin, so ich bin auf dem weg, ja, max was sagt die brandweite,
ja ich weiß auch nicht, das wort hat es mir heute echt angetan, max welche musik hörst
du, hauptsächlich heavy metal, hardrock heavy metal, wobei ich mittlerweile auch viele anderen
geschichten mir gebe, es geht sogar so weit, dass ich mittlerweile irgendwelche hiphop und
rap geschichten höre, sogar so was Richtung haftbefehl und so was, aber hauptsächlich
hardrock und heavy metal, eigentlich kann ich mich unmuted lassen, weil unsere beiden
sind nicht so schnell, da kann man eigentlich beide was sagen, moment warum läuft bdo eigentlich
mit adminberechtigung, hä, deswegen geht das overlay nicht, das overlay geht nicht, weil
bdo irgendwie als admin läuft oder so was, das ist ja richtig fail, null, hyperlull, null
3d, hab nur ich das gefühl oder kommt in letzter zeit keine guten games mehr raus,
sag ich gleich was zu, muss ich gleich mal anti-muten wieder, also hier das discord bedienen
aus bdo ist übelst fail, warum, na du kannst normalerweise kannst du so ein overlay im spiel
einplenden, da sieht man was die leute, also wer labert und so was und man sieht ob man
gemuted ist oder nicht gemuted ist und vor allem funktionieren dann wenn man das overlay
hat auch die hotkeys in game, sowas für mutant and mutant und das geht mit bdo nicht, das
geht mit fast jedem game bisher wo ich es ausprobiert hab gehts, bdo gehts natürlich
nicht, weil bdo, ich vermute mal weil bdo als admin gestartet ist, weiß ich nicht genau,
also ich bin jetzt hier am spot, ich renn bei kuscher herum, es hat grad bei mir einer
im chat gefragt ob wir das gefühl haben, ich mach das jetzt einfach mal für uns beide,
dass in letzter zeit keine gescheiten games rauskommen, bzw. hat irgendwie den eindruck
die games die rauskommen verkacken ihr potential, ich denk das ist vor allem wenn man sich mal,
wie hieß dieses, weißt du das noch wie dieses eine mmo hieß, wo sie wieder auf dicke hose
gemacht haben, so nach dem motto wird world events das hier und sowieso und das beste
aller Zeiten werden, wo wir beide schon gesagt haben wir glauben nicht dran und das wirds
wahrscheinlich wieder verkacken, welches menzen bless oder was, war das bless, das ich
weiß gar nicht was das war, ich weiß bloß dass da so ein paar entwickler rumgehockt
haben und halt erzählt haben so nach dem motto die besten world events und die besten hier
und die besten die besten von allem und wo wir beide halt schon unsere zweifel hatten
dass das was klappt, es könnte bless, nee was gibt es denn sonst noch, sogar was kam
da noch, dann wirds wahrscheinlich bless gewesen sein, ich frag bless, so wir müssen erst mal
irgendwie einen freien channel finden, das ist das problem, ich hätte nie gedacht dass
hier überhaupt ein mensch grindet, also ich bin mit ihr drei, guckt mal ob da jemand ist,
ja ich reite gerade hin, aha das spiel, das problem war anscheinend schrei mit dem chat
welche mehrere mit discord ein bdo schon gehabt, sucked, le lupe, le lupe, wie es bei bdo immer
alles aufploppt, ich geh jetzt mal rüber und guck mal ob da was grindet, ich habe eine
grunnel armor, grunnel armor, ja das bist du rich, grunnel, aber ich glaube sogar die
leute die über steam angefangen haben sind jetzt über grunnel raus, grunnel sind grunnel,
spielen keine grunnel mehr, ja grunnel ist outdated, prüste ich mein lag, also es sieht
hier auf den ersten blick mal noch recht frei aus, welchen, also das sieht frei aus, ist
da ein richtiger spot, ja, welches mit dir drei oder was, ja die mobs, ich weiß noch
wie ich mich mit einem abgequält habe als der spot neu war mit dem wizard, wie ewig
ich gebraucht habe für die mobs, jetzt bisschen abgequält als letztes mal hier mit items
und so, überhaupt kein ding mehr, können ja gar nichts mehr, ja das stimmt schon, easy,
hast du, ich muss mich noch mal muten hier, max hast du viel erfahrung mit g-sync oder
freesync und wenn ja wie viel aufpreis würdest du max dafür bezahlen, also, ich habe, ich
hatte einen g-sync monitor von nvidia, warte mal ich muss mal kurz mal den discord, party
grinder, so ich habe mich gerade gemutet, alles was bedeutet das, alles über blue oder
was, was, oder nur blue oder nur green, mache einfach alles green oder und der rest free,
du redest mit dem chat oder, ja, ok ich bin verwirrt, ich habe gerade gefragt wie das
geht, weil ich ja nie in eine gruppe grinder, das weiß da keiner, das hat der karsten gewusst
jetzt, da hat es nämlich auch immer eingestellt, also ich mute mich mal zwischendurch immer,
weil hier chat will keine irgendwelche dinger wissen, easy mute, so g-sync, also ich hatte
einen g-sync monitor von nvidia von aoc, hieß das glaube ich, der hersteller, aoc und ich
muss ehrlich gesagt, ich muss gestehen, ich habe jetzt den unterschied zwischen g-sync
und nicht g-sync nicht großartig gemerkt, vor allem in hohen fps zahlen, und ihr kennt
mich ja mittlerweile, wenn ich games spiele, dann spiele ich die immer auf so low settings
wie irgendwie geht, dass ich 144 plus fps kriege und da hat sich, ich habe es ehrlich
gesagt nicht gemerkt und dementsprechend tendiere ich dazu, für mich lohnt sich das nicht und
großartig aufpreis, will ich dafür auch nicht ausgeben, den nächsten monitor den ich mir
kaufe, der ist höchstwahrscheinlich dann mit 4k 144 fps und hdr und geschiss, wenn es
dann mal einen gibt.
Dein eigener bdo account oder hat der friseur den dir gesellt, was nein, das ist meiner,
das hat mir nicht der friseur gesellt, ich habe beim thema selten, ich glaube ich krieg
auch gole von farian, das ranger krill da flitzt es rum, ach gestellt, ich habe gesellt
verstanden, es ist weder gestellt noch gesellt, das ist mein bdo account schon seit einem
jahr oder so, aber ich habe halt kaum playtime, dafür habe ich übertrieben gutes gier trotz
kaum playtime, weil wir das rng glück des todes hatten, also leute ich lasse den chat
offen und wenn im chat was gefragt wird oder was uns beide betrifft, mute ich mich nicht
und da fragen wir farian auch dazu und wenn es irgendwas spezifisches ist oder wenn er
gerade mit seinem chat labert, dann mute ich mich, so machen wir das, das ranger krill flitzt,
das glaube ich das einzige, was die meisten anderen klassen besser haben als der wizard,
das rum flitzen können, aber wobei es außerhalb vom fight auch egal ist, du hast ja deinen
speed buff als wizard und kannst ja mit endo run mittlerweile eine halbe stunde gefühlt
sprinten, ja die mana kugel, die nna, die gibt ihr aus, soll ich vielleicht mal anmachen
wo wir gerade dabei sind, hoffen speed, der wird jetzt outgrindet, der typ
das rng glück hatte, ich glaube wir haben da nix aufgenommen von, oder haben wir da
irgendwas von aufgenommen, nee haben wir nicht, muss man bei clips gucken, bei clips sind
welche, aber nur mal so zur erklärung, wir haben ja fast alles aus dem auktionshaus gesniped,
on stream und ich hatte übelst glück dabei, also total übertrieben, einzige, was ich selbst
vom gear gekriegt habe, oder selbst gefunden habe, ist die 3 spirit armor aus einer event
kiste oder aus einer daily reward kiste, oder sowas, muss man sich mal vorstellen, ey,
Und die masken schuhe zweite woche wo ich die quest gemacht habe aus der aus der box von der quest
Also mega eigentlich noch mehr rng carried als ich deswegen sollte ich bei dir mal keiner beschweren
streamer lag
Ich habe ja nicht mal gestreamt
Du hast danach angefangen
Wie lange dauert es bis level 60 übel schnell
Ja jetzt mit den neuen ab übel schnell
Keine ahnung wie lange brauche man denn also
Ich habe wie lange habe ich denn gebraucht ich meine ich habe gesagt
Da war irgendwie so hier jetzt geht es los und irgendwie war ich gefühlt. Du hast ja aber auch schon gegrindet wo ich war vorher schon
55 oder so prozent ja und dann irgendwie drei tage später war ich irgendwie 60
Also ich denke mal
So bis 58 oder so kommst du wahrscheinlich in einem tag wenn du schon ein bisschen ahnung von dem game hast oder was das
Tu ja denke ich auch
Und wenn du neu ist wenn du neu bist
Ich meine selbst wenn man neu ist und man sagt man mal du brauchst einen monat auf auf das level oder länger ist ja nicht
Schlimm solange mit der zeit irgendwas macht also sprich wenn zeit halt dafür braucht um dich mit dem game auseinander zu setzen
Dann ist es ja nicht verschwendet
Genau kanns tutorials gucken aber es geht halt mega schnell im vergleich zu früher
Ja um ist der schnitzel auch ich habe noch battlefield server
Nur aber sind Renshakes Abenteuer
Bringt ihr eigentlich dieser speed buff,was?
klar
Alter, jetzt kann irgend so ein Griefplatt wieder an, ey.
Du musst mal ihn baschen.
Ich schütze auch.
Rekt!
Ah, Hardcore schreckt, ey.
Der kommt jetzt wieder und will uns bomben.
Ja klar, das sind wieder solche Trashies, ey.
Können wir dann gleich mal War anmachen.
Dann kriegen wir wieder einen Gilgen-Tankshow, Guestbook-Eintrag.
Und The Fate of the World?
Player Wubblos.
Wie geht das?
Ja, irgendwie so.
Blabla, Blabla bei Relics.
Ja.
Und als vielleicht erwischt, haben wir eine Klärle im Stream.
Ich habe das Game, glaube ich, irgendwie zwei Wochen mit dem Wizard gespielt oder so.
Und wir haben an diesem Relics, wie heißt denn das, diese normalen Relic-Shots, die
man kriegt, wo man die Memory-Fragment-Rollen macht, haben wir halt irgend so einen Typ,
einfach habe ich halt, einfach Weg-Picard, der da rumgestanden hat, afk mit irgend so
einem Trade-Wagen.
Und danach gab es Dick im Gilgen-Guestbook erstmal Eintrag hier, wo er mich geflammt hat.
Warum gehst du nicht, Addicted?
Wozu soll dich?
Was ist halt, was ich halt relativ, also was mich instant abgetürmt hat bei Addicted,
also Blasey hatte mich ja mal gefragt, ob ich joinen will, habe ich gesagt, nee, lieber
nee.
Und was mich ja aber abgetürmt hat, was mich halt nicht so, was mich halt instant gleich
gestört hat, dass der Gilden-Leader, ich mache mal kurz, jetzt kann ich mal hier fragen
mal, gibt es mit deinem Gear eigentlich noch Gegner, die du nicht wegkommst?
Mein Gear ist nicht gut, also mein Gear ist gut für die Zeit, wo ich spiele, ja, für
die Zeit, wo ich spiele ist mein Gear übertrieben gut, aber ansonsten im Vergleich zu anderen
ist mein Gear trash, ja ich habe keinen gescheiten Schmuck, ich habe den Quest-Schmuck, habe
meine Sachen auch nur auf 3, habe noch keine Boss-Waffe hier, also es ist ein riesen Unterschied.
Beim Fabian sieht es ein bisschen anders aus, der Fabian hat ja übertrieben guten Schmuck
und auch sonst extrem gutes Gear, wenn da jetzt nicht gerade der PvP-Pro kommt, rubbelt
er alles weg.
Und um was zu diesem Battlefield 4 Server, ich habe übrigens Mist erzählt, ich habe
kein Battlefield 4 Server, ich habe einen Battlefield 3 Server.
Alter, blödsinn, was ich erzählt habe.
Ich muss auch sagen, das war die übelste Überforderung, mit Chat gucken, dann mich
zwischentretend im Discord muten und so, das ist total weird.
Ja, Club Toka, das stimmt schon, aber wie gesagt, ich sage ja immer, ich bin der bestausgerüstete
Loop im Video, weil ich von dem Game an sich keinen Plastenschimmer habe, aber RNG-Luck.
Bist du afk?
Achso, ich bin da, ja kann ich schreiben.
Ja, den fahren wir ruhig ab, Typen.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du sie wieder an die Waren, dass du irgendeinem Pleb-Guilde bist.
Immer klein wahren, gar nicht erst fragen, kannst du den Channel switchen, wir erklären
das wie Männer.
2 gegen 1, schreckt.
Hier wird instant klein Krieg angemacht.
Ja, ich meine, ihr könnt ja Verstärkung holen.
Genau, und wir haben ein bisschen Spaß.
Ja, wir haben ein bisschen Spaß.
Zum Thema Overwatch League, gerade im Chat gesehen habe, ich gucke Overwatch League.
Ich habe vorgestern nicht geguckt, ich meine, das ist ja zu, Overwatch League läuft ja zu
den mit Abstand besten EU-Zeiten, die ich je gesehen habe, also irgendwann nachts ab
1 bis 5, das kann man also nicht gucken, wenn man arbeiten geht.
Ich habe das letzte bisschen gesehen von Dallas gegen Soul Dynasty und gestern Nacht, also
gestern auf heute Nacht habe ich die ersten eineinhalb Games geguckt, da bin ich eingepennt.
Und ich habe zugeguckt, wie Dallas wieder auf den Sack gekriegt hat, von einem Team,
wo ich es echt nicht gedacht hätte.
Fabian, wenn er wieder kommt, ich stehe das nächste Mal.
Schaffst du nicht.
Schaffe ich nicht.
Kannst ja mit draufhornern.
Du wirst ja nicht so viel Karma verlieren.
Ja, das denke ich jetzt.
Ach, 95.
Geht noch.
Hast du das Loot verteilen?
Jetzt kannst du anmachen, Max.
Hast du das Loot verteilen an?
Ja.
Okay.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was PK anmachen ist, Steuerung C dachte ich, aber Steuerung C geht
nicht.
Alt C.
Das ist eher auch, das ist auch ein Kerber, das juckt den eh.
Nee, nee, eigentlich kann man den nur grinden lassen.
Das ist dem wurscht.
Bei dir im Chat schreibt gerade einer, der Mob hat mehr Leben als der Typ.
Das sah echt so aus.
Die Mops kippen um wie nix.
Get Shrecked, Mops.
Highskill 3 Justin Char ist am Start.
Du caries nicht, nice.
Du bist der Tatversorger.
Mit drei spells, ne?
Ja.
Aber das ist ein riesen Unterschied.
Seit dem letzten Upgrade, da haben wir nicht, wir haben gar nicht so viel Progress gemacht,
ein bisschen, ja.
Aber das ist ein riesen Unterschied.
Das Zula Set haben wir halt, glaub ich, ne?
Genau, das ist der hauptsächliche Unterschied.
Ich, wie gesagt, kann mich ja noch dran erinnern, als ich den Spot hier mal mit dem Karsten gemacht
hab, noch mit der alten Ausrüstung, das hat ewig gedauert.
Okay.
Also gefühlt, ne?
Hier macht jetzt jeder von uns zwei spells, die Mops sind tot.
Nein, du machst zwei spells, ich mach zehn.
Aber das ist ein riesen Unterschied.
Ich muss mal gucken, wie wir das in Zukunft machen mit, wenn wir beide streben, dass wir
uns nicht selber gegenseitig reinlammern und dass Mutant und Endmutant so ordentlich funktioniert,
dass wir noch den richtigen Flow finden für.
Gibt es in deinem Haus wirklich noch den Aufzug oder hast du den weggemacht?
Den gibt's nicht mehr.
Den gibt's nicht mehr, den Aufzug.
Der musste weg, weil man sonst das Dach nicht richtig isoliert kriegt.
Deswegen musste der Aufzug weg.
Schade, ja?
Also ich fand den Aufzug geil.
Also erstens, weil er den Opa gebaut hat.
Und zweitens, ich mein, wer hat schon einen Aufzug, um auf sein Dach zu fahren?
Also aus diesen beiden Gesichtspunkten fand ich den Aufzug geil, aber leider, leider weg.
Eats Ass Knowledge.
Ja, mega Glück.
Ich bin übertrieben Glück.
Ich hab mich mit dem Mob fünfmal gebashed.
Easy Ass Knowledge.
Und mein Overwatch League geht jetzt gerade los oder wie?
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Moment, Moment.
Moment.
Ernsthaft?
Die spielen schon?
Alter Blizzard.
Wie soll man sich darauf denn einstellen?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Overwatch jetzt läuft, sonst hätte ich Overwatch geguckt.
Aber jetzt muss gebashed werden.
Jetzt ist zu spät.
Jetzt läuft er wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Stunden.
Da kann ich nachher noch ein paar Games gucken.
Wer ist denn heute dran?
Was ist das jemand?
Welche Teams OWL heute am Start sind?
Das ist ja mal eine gute Zeit.
Zwanzig Uhr.
Zwanzig Uhr EU.
Da kann ich mit leben.
Ich mach Live-Commentary.
Nee, darf ich bestimmt nicht zeigen.
Also ich habe noch nicht mal gefragt und ich werde auch nicht fragen, weil man kann mit Sicherheit davon ausgehen, dass das kein anderer Channel einfach so zeigen darf.
Hast du dir ein paar Bilder vom Opa aufgehängt?
Ja habe ich.
Haben wir.
Haben wir hier.
Nein, die haben wir nicht aufgehängt.
Die Bilder von den nackten Mädels.
Ich meine, ich kann mir das schon vorstellen.
Das hat meinem Opa bestimmt Spaß gemacht zu malen.
Brauchst du dir die passenden Models für?
Was mich jetzt im Nachhinein, was ich mich so frage ist, was da meine Oma zugesagt hat.
Ich meine, meine Oma kann das doch nicht sonderlich toll gefunden haben.
Wenn da irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, paar und zwanzigjährigen Mädels nackig beim Opa oben im Atelier gelegen haben und haben sich malen.
Das fand ich doch bestimmt nicht so toll.
Zu meiner Einschätzung nach.
Mehr BDO in Zukunft.
Meine letzten paar Streams waren auch schon die ganze Zeit BDO.
Heute ist halt ein bisschen kompliziert mit Discord hier.
Hast du eigentlich schon einziges Mal ein Battle Royale Spiel gespielt?
Ja habe ich.
Ich habe mit dem Eaxe ein bisschen PUBG gespielt.
Und ich habe mir damals zu Release.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mich da gerippen hat, ehrlich gesagt.
Zu Release habe ich mir H1, Z1 geholt.
Damals, als es noch Sony war.
Weiß auch nicht warum.
Damals war das Game ja auch noch gar nicht, noch gar nicht Battle Royale.
Aber PUBG habe ich gespielt und habe festgestellt, dass mir PUBG nicht gefällt.
Und ich noch nicht mal genau sagen kann, was mir an PUBG eigentlich nicht gefällt.
Aber PUBG macht.
Es ist nicht mein Game.
Und ich spiele ja BDO.
Jetzt mal, hat es mit dem Battle Royale nichts zu tun.
Ich spiele ja BDO hauptsächlich deswegen, weil ich dann mit Fabian mal wieder was spielen kann.
Wenn ich jetzt dann auch jetzt nicht andere Games wieder anfange, dann kommen wir wieder nicht dazu was zusammen zu spielen.
Und übrigens mit Overwatch reicht es mir jetzt erstmal.
Ich kann überhaupt mal drauf.
Das tiltet mich so übelst das Game.
Ich werde jetzt erstmal passiv gucken.
Overwatch League.
Und dann vielleicht ein paar Monate oder so wieder spielen.
Falls es greift, dieses neue SA System.
Dass die Matches besser werden.
Dann spiele ich wieder.
Ich würde ja gerne Overwatch weiterspielen.
Ich finde es immer noch ein geiles Game im Kern.
Die Mops aufploppen.
Lull.
Als nächstes gibt es BDO Battle Royale.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
Es wird mich nicht ganz ehrlich.
Alles was Kohle bringt.
Blizzard lässt sich einfach zu viel Zeit.
Ja finde ich auch.
Welches neue SA System?
Es ist jetzt so, du kannst jetzt nur noch mit Leuten gruppen, die näher beieinander sind.
Und es wird jetzt auch nicht mehr bewertet.
Wie gut du gewesen bist in der Runde.
Sondern es kriegen alle gleich viel bei einem Win-Loss.
Aber wisst ihr was ich gut finde, wo wir gerade dabei sind bei Overwatch.
Ich bin ja so froh, dass Mercy auf dem PTR schon mal genervt ist.
Und wisst ihr was ich noch viel geiler fand?
Das Geheul in der Mop.
Ich bin ja so froh, dass sie auf dem PTR schon mal genervt ist.
Und wisst ihr was ich noch viel geiler fand?
Das Geheul in der Mop.
Das Geheul in der Mercy Mainz.
Ich bin ja normalerweise nicht irgendwie sadistisch veranlagt oder so.
Aber das hat mich richtig innerlich gefreut.
Dieser Heul-Post im Battle.net Forum zu lesen.
Mir ging da so richtig das Herz auf.
Ich habe mir gedacht, Alter, euch geschieht es nicht besser.
Weißt du, das sind dann Leute, wo du dann in das Profil guckst.
Und siehst halt irgendwie 720 Stunden Mercy oder sowas.
Sonst nichts.
Das fand ich super.
Ich hoffe die Challenges kommen genau so.
Und dass alle, dass die Morte erstmal weg ist jetzt.
Ich muss mal den Fabian kurz fragen, ob jetzt die Gilde schon auf Krieg kam.
Sieht aber nicht so aus.
Haben wir die Gilde jetzt schon auf Krieg?
Nee, gell?
Ich glaube da reagiert keiner bei uns.
Hast du eigentlich schon mal ein Battle Royale-Game gespielt?
Nee.
Nee?
Nein.
Hast du noch kein Video gespielt?
Nee.
Hast doch keinen Bock drauf, ne?
Du musst BDO crime.
Ja, BDO beste.
Wenn man BDO spielt, kann man kein anderes spielen.
Vielleicht gibt es ja dann nächstes Kakaobattle-Royale.
Die machen ja nichts selbst, Pearl Abyss Battle Royale.
Das ist so nervig, Alter.
Das hasse ich an solchen Spots, weißt du?
Dass der den Typen hier mit rumge...
Na ja, gut.
Ja, guck mal, der kam angeritten und hat gesehen, dass wir hier sind, weißt du?
Ja, du kannst halt nichts dagegen machen.
Wir können ihn jetzt killen im Endeffekt, aber bringt nichts.
Und oben leveln oder mal drei, weißt du?
Hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass hier...
Ich hab den extra ausgewählt, damit halt, weißt du?
Oh, ich sollte vielleicht mal meine 200% XP anmachen.
Lul.
Gleich mal nach dem Pull hier.
Was meinste?
Soll ich jetzt...
Soll ich Skill-XP anmachen oder XP?
Also Mob-XP oder Skill-XP?
Wobei, kann man das überhaupt auswählen?
Nee, das ist auf eben, Buff.
Ach, das ist alles in einem System hier.
Ja.
Wie die O-Pro in Aktion, wie man sieht.
Bei deinem Energy-Ding würde ich Skill-XP nehmen, statt XP.
Gerade beim Wizard.
1660 wirst du so schnell genug.
Am Ende hast du immer noch zu wenig Skill-Points.
Stimmt, den Energy-Buff.
Den Energy-Buff meinste, du wirst zu Skill nehmen?
Skill-Points, ja.
Weil das Problem ist halt nie Leveln, sondern Skill-Points.
Am Ende.
Na, wie gesagt, Leveln ist halt easy as fuck geworden.
Und dann stehst du da mit deinen 61, mit deinen 1.100 Points.
Du hast keine Skill-Points.
Ja, stimmt.
Ich bash den jetzt.
Oh, ich probier's mal.
Machst jetzt krass PVP-Action.
Ich mach krass PVP.
Noob gegen Noob ist das jetzt.
Der will überhaupt nicht.
Der hat keinen Bock.
Nee, nee, das ist halt...
Das dauert kein PVP an.
Doch, hatte ich, hatte ich.
Jetzt hab ich wieder ausgemacht.
Wer kämpfen wollen solche?
Nee.
Wie viele Skill-Points habe ich?
Ich glaube 1.700 oder so.
War deine Pets eigentlich gefeedet?
Jo.
Okay, der macht wirklich keinen Damage.
Noob gegen Noob.
Achtung, richtiges Battle.
Krass, ich hab kein Pet raus.
Fällt mir grad auf.
Sag mal, warum entfleckt mich das eigentlich immer?
Dann drückst du falsche Taste wahrscheinlich.
Du bist nie mehr entfleckt.
Du bist nie entfleckt, glaub ich.
Nee, hast recht.
Warum ist...
Okay, wenn es dieses rote Ding ist,
dann zeigt das nur an, dass ich gefleckt bin.
Und wenn die Schwärter kommt, heißt das,
ich hab's quasi engaged.
Oder wie ist das?
Ja, genau.
Ach so.
Also dann, wenn die Schwärter kommen,
bist du gefleckt.
Das bedeutet, jeder kann dich in der Zeit angreifen.
Verstehe.
Ich muss mich nochmal kurz muten.
Questions beantworten.
Du als Mercy-Main müsstest dich eigentlich
mit den Nerven besonders aufregen.
Ja, genau.
So sieht's aus, Leute.
Ich als Mercy-Main.
Ich bin ja bekannt dafür, ein Mercy-Main zu sein.
Äh, Moment.
Boah krass, ich hab irgendwie keinen Mana mehr.
Was wird an Mercy genervt?
Also ziemlich alles.
Du hast kein...
Boah, ich krieg's jetzt leider aus dem Kopf
nicht mehr so hundertprozentig zusammen.
Also, du hast weniger Geschwindigkeit, deine Ult.
Also, ich glaub, du hast weniger Geschwindigkeit
in deiner Ult.
Die Rätsel sind in der Ult nicht mehr instant.
Ähm, also alles.
Ich sag, es ist alles kacke.
Ich glaub sogar, die Ult dauert.
Es ist jetzt im Prinzip viel, viel schlechter
als vorher.
Aber mal abwarten.
Ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen,
die Fähigkeit generell Spieler wiederzubeleben
ist an sich mit das Opeste, was es an Ability
in dem ganzen Spiel gibt.
Weil kriegst du nur zwei gute oder kriegst du nur
ein oder sagen wir mal, im besten Fall
zwei gute Rätsels raus, hast du quasi schon
Spieler mehr als die Gegner.
Also wenn jetzt irgendwie Teamfight ist
oder sagen wir so, es muss ja nicht mal richtig
Teamfight sein.
Es kann ja einfach nur so ein bisschen
rumgespammer sein, ja.
Die Mops bewegen sich nicht.
Es kann einfach nur so ein bisschen
rumgespammer sein.
Es stirbt dir einer.
So, und ansonsten müsst du erstmal regroupen
30 Minuten später hin und her.
Und da drückst du einfach deinen Rest.
Also Rest ist das Opeste, was es in dem Game gibt.
Das heißt, es kann sogar sein, dass Mercy
selbst nach dem Nerf noch gar nicht mal
so kacke ist.
Das muss ich dann mal zeigen.
Wird Mana per Autoattack Restored?
Ja.
Also Mana wird im Prinzip für fast
allem Restored.
Mana wird mit Autoattack Restored.
Mana wird hier mit diesem Dash Restored.
Und halt, ich glaube hier nach Mop-Hit.
Das heißt, wenn ich hier diesen A.E. in Mops
reinmache, kriege ich halt Instant-Mana.
Wenn ich jetzt einzelne, einzelne
Leute fighten würde, kriege ich nicht so
viel Mana.
Weil es halt nur ein Target ist.
Wann spielst du Call of David Wanderhaar?
Nein, das ist falsch.
David Wanderhaar Battlegrounds heißt das.
Ich glaube, von der Guild ist keiner da,
der Krieg anmachen kann.
So wie es aussieht.
Aber es ist nicht so schlimm.
Ich meine, der stört jetzt auch nicht so krass.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist ja nicht so,
als hätten wir zu wenig Mops.
Ja.
Sagen wir mal, klitschen die Mops bei dir
auch übelst rum, dass die in der Luft rumrennen
und sowas?
Nö.
Also das heißt, in der Luft rennen,
manchmal stehen bleiben und auf der Stelle
rennen und so.
Nö.
Ich glaube, ich habe packetloss.
Du merkst den BDO eh nicht richtig.
BDO ist da relativ resistent dagegen.
Guck, jetzt rennt er schon wieder in
der Luft rum.
Ach ja, doch, habe ich, sehe ich.
Ja.
Da liegt es an BDO-Servern.
Bei mir im Chat schreibt keiner,
ob der Wizard später noch
mehr Fähigkeiten kriegt.
Das sieht ganz schön lame aus,
dass er so wenig hat.
Der Wizard hat mehr als diese drei Spells,
die ich hier die ganze Zeit mache.
Der Wizard hat ziemlich viele Spells.
Wenn du in den Skills hier mal reinguckst,
du hast massig Spells.
Nur weil ich nur drei Spells verwende,
heißt es nicht, dass du nur drei Spells hast.
Ich verwende im Endeffekt eigentlich nichts
von den Spells, die ich habe,
außer halt die drei, die man braucht
zum Gegnerkillen.
Die reichen.
Du musst ein bisschen mehr verwenden,
ne?
Als Ranger-Kill.
Ja, die Klasse muss mehr verwenden
als Witch-Wizard.
Also außer PvP, dann ist es eigentlich
relativ ausgeglichen.
Der PvP brauchst du ja auch als Wizard mehr.
Ja.
Dann hast du echt relativ viele Skills.
Schulz.
Schulzerino?
Ich glaube, ich bin in die andere Richtung
gedashed.
Aber trotzdem gedashed erst mal hier
das Mob-Pack.
Das Mobbett?
Das Mobbett, ja.
Max programmiert ein eigenes Battle-Card-Game.
Genau.
Morgen kommt es raus.
Easy.
Brauchst du auch kein Geld dafür, Max.
YouTube-Money-Carried.
Ne, ich mache das alleine.
Ich brauche gar nichts für.
Ganz alleine.
Ich meine, wenn so ein kleiner Indie-Developer
wie Blizzard ein Game wie Overwatch aus dem
Hut zaubert, dann kann ich auch mein eigenes
Battle-Card-Game machen.
Ja, und vor allem brauche ich ja auch Battle-Fit
viel weniger.
Wie soll ich sagen?
Viel weniger Charakter-Design, ne?
Da kannst du dir über das Charakter-Design
gar nicht so viele Gedanken machen.
Einfach ein paar Waffen und dann easy.
Ne, ich mache das ganz billig.
Ich glaube, die Models und so einfach aus
anderen Games.
Das machen viele Asia-Free-to-Play-Games
und sowas auch.
Das krasseste, was ich mal gesehen habe,
war ein Game, habe ich in Review geguckt
auf YouTube, was von eins zu eins Maps aus
CSGO extrahiert hat.
Irgendso ein Asia-Shooter war das.
Irgendso ein Asia-Pay-To-In-Shooter.
Hat aus CSGO Maps extrahiert und hat dann
halt aus einer Wüsten-Map eine Stadt-Map gemacht.
Problem ist halt, der Boden sah immer noch
nach Sand aus.
Also weißt du, der Boden war so geformt
wie Sand.
Halt so wellig.
Und es war halt eine Steintextur drüber.
Weil Stadt-Map.
Richtig billig.
Das dreht sich aber ganz chillig hier.
Ja, das ist angenehm.
Wo sieht man jetzt eigentlich was getroppt
auf dem Beutel da, ne?
Ne, guck einfach in deinen...
Das wird gerade in Special Deals
die ganze Zeit verkauft.
Ja, ich sehe es.
Aber wenn man auf den Beutel klickt,
sieht man auch, was gerade drinnen ist.
Ach so.
Wie ist der Beutel los?
Oh, ein Blackstone.
Easy.
Kann man rollen.
Kennst du das, dieses Asia-Overwatch-Fake?
Hast du da mal ein Video von gesehen?
Ne.
Das sieht wirklich, also ich glaube sogar
ein Mobile-Game.
Das sieht einfach eins zu eins aus
wie Overwatch.
Die haben sogar die Icons
und so geklaut aus dem Game.
Okay, krass.
Oh, der hat...
Der hat sich geflaggt.
Was ist mit dem los?
Der hat sich geflaggt?
Der Typ.
Echt?
Ja.
Ach, wir haben Gildenkrieg jetzt.
Easy.
Jetzt wird er geschreckt.
Jetzt wird er dauernd geschreckt.
Jetzt wird es geschreckt.
Jetzt kommt er wahrscheinlich nimmer.
Ach, das ist immer so.
Das ist ein Video-Game.
Ihr wisst, ich hätte ja nichts gemacht.
Ich hätte gar nichts gemacht.
Wenn der durch uns durchgeritten wäre...
In die gleichen Mob-Packs rein wäre, ne?
...und dann instantiv dort jetzt war, wo wir waren.
Dann hätte ich nie was gesagt.
Weißt du, wenn wir da zugekommen wären,
hätte ich den noch gar nicht erst angegriffen.
Da ist er.
Aber das ist halt...
Das ist halt ein Streist, finde ich.
Der hat echt weniger Leben als die Mops.
Ja.
Das, finde ich, den halt schon dreist.
Er ist wieder da.
Okay, soll ich mal weiterkreiseln?
Ja.
Kreisel mal weiter.
Du musst den Nut ins Horst packen.
Streamt doch Black Ops gemeinsam.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist abgefahren mittlerweile.
Würdest du noch mal ein Black Ops spielen,
wenn noch eins rauskommt?
Ich?
Ja.
Nee, ich spiele kein...
Ja, Kod ist durch.
Kein Bock mehr auf die Serie.
Das spiele ich lieber Gear Software weiter.
Das nächste soll ja auf den PC kommen.
Ja, echt?
Habe ich gelesen, ja.
Das ist ja dieses Games for Windows, oder wie das heißt.
Was du quasi...
Xbox-Spiele jetzt auch auf dem PC spielen kannst.
Okay.
Da bin ich mal...
Also, was heißt Xbox-Spiele auch auf dem PC?
Es gibt halt dann einfach eine PC-Version, eine Xbox-Version.
Okay.
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Gehst vor.
Dark Age of Camelot könnt ihr auch mal streamen.
Nee, das sind...
Ich glaube, da haben wir mittlerweile beide abgehakt.
Ja, das ist halt einfach erstens viel zu lange her.
Und man muss sagen, also im Vergleich zu BDO,
Trigger Dark in PvP zu sehr.
Man wird halt untereinander schneller match...
Man regt sich auf, ja.
Ich meine, wir kacken uns normalerweise nie an, ne?
Außer in Dark.
Ja, also was heißt, wir haben uns...
Naja, nee, wir haben uns nicht wirklich geflatet.
Aber normalerweise...
Wir waren halt ein bisschen zwischendrin angepisst,
weil jeder dachte, der hat den besseren Move gemacht.
Genau.
Aber im Prinzip hat es halt nie wirklich...
Keiner verkackt.
Das ist halt dann auch ein bisschen...
Zumal Daox halt das Problem ist,
wenn du da jetzt mit einem Char spielst.
Wir haben uns da damals sogar, waren wir richtig bescheuert,
haben uns neue Chars gemacht.
Und da waren wir halt irgendwie Reichsrang 3
gegen irgendwie die ganzen real rank 11 Typen da aus US.
Das geht halt.
Aber gut, ich meine, es war jetzt nicht so schlecht.
Also wir haben schon ganz gut was gemacht.
Nee, das ging schon.
Das ging schon.
Mittlerweile gibt es ja wohl nochmal eine neue Grenzgebiet in Daox.
Okay.
Seit einer Weile.
Das hat jetzt ja ein anderer Anbieter übernommen.
Und das Einzige, wo ich wieder Daox spielen würde,
oder könntest du mir vorstellen, dass du da auch dabei wärst,
ist, wenn sie einen neuen Server releasen,
der ein neues Regelset hat.
Ja.
Also, weißt du...
Vanilla and Chain released ja irgendwann zwischen Soon und ein paar Jahre.
Ja gut, das Problem ist,
ich habe halt so einen Bauchgefühl, dass mir das eh nicht gefallen wird.
Ich glaube auch.
Ich glaube mittlerweile auch Camelot und Chained ist
nicht das, was ich gehofft habe.
Das ist einfach RIP.
Weil das Ding ist auch unabhängig davon,
dass Gruppen-Content in BDO nie so geil ist,
aber BDO hat für mich neue MMO-Maßstäbe geschafft.
Erstens, was das Gear-Progression angeht,
dass auch so Leute wie ich, die alles, sage ich mal so, suchten
und dann auch, weiß ich nie, vieles planen und so.
Das macht einfach Bock hier, das Spiel zu spielen mit dem Enchant-System
und dann auch noch das actionreiche Kampfsystem.
Also ich werde nur nie wieder in MMO zocken,
was irgendwie Taktargeting oder 123456 pressen
und Abilities durchjagen.
Das muss halt genauso wie BDO sein.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, wie das wird in Camelot und Chained.
Also das ist, ich bin mir nämlich ganz sicher,
ich habe ja mal am Anfang diese Early-Insider-Alpha ein bisschen gespielt.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnern kann, das war nicht Tab-Target-System,
das war aber auch nicht wie BDO, das war eher so ein, keine Ahnung.
Wenn es so ein Mix ist wie bei Terra, dann ist es ja in Ordnung.
Ich glaube, du musstest aimen mit Zaubern und sowas.
Ja, das, wenn es wie mit Terra ist, ist es in Ordnung.
Ich muss auch mal...
Ja, ich muss auch mal ins Boss.
Da war das ja auch eher mehr 12345, aber schon irgendwie mit...
Du musstest aimen, genau.
Mit aiming.
Ja, ich bringe mal kurz Zeug zum Hors.
Ja, mach das.
Nee, aber ich habe irgendwie auch so ein Bauchgefühl,
Camelot und Chained wird nicht so das Game, wie ich es mir erhofft habe.
Du hast ja quasi kaum PvM-Content.
Also Monster Bash ist gar nicht.
Na gut, was jetzt nicht so schlimm wäre.
Also ein bisschen zur Entspannung finde ich das schon ganz gut,
wenn du einfach mal ein bisschen Monster Bash machen kannst.
Und was mir gar nicht gefällt, wobei da noch nicht so richtig klar ist,
wie es ins Game integriert werden wird.
Und ich glaube, das geht dir auch so, ist dieses Minecraft-Bausystem.
Ja, das interessiert mich gar mehr.
Und wenn alle Gebäude in Camelot und Chained dann mit diesem komischen
Minecraft-Bausystem sind, dann sieht es...
Also dann macht es, glaube ich, mir keinen Bock.
Und vor allem, es sieht schon so kacke aus.
Ich meine, ein ordentliches Haus von irgendeinem Typ,
der das gebaut hat in seinem 3D-Editor,
ist besser als ein Minecraft-Haus in der Welt,
die nicht nach Minecraft aussieht.
Ja, ich bin wieder am Start.
Wo stellt es denn das Ranger Grill gerade?
Ranger Grill ist am Beach.
Gönnt sich.
Volle Gönnung.
Richtige Gönnung.
Da ist es.
Das Ranger Grill macht Progress.
Ich habe es übrigens aufgegeben, ne?
Was denn?
Mit anderen Chars leveln.
Hast doch keinen Bock.
Ich habe dir letztens gesagt, dann level ich meinen DK oder meine...
Deine Witch wolltest du leveln?
Meine Witch, aber ich bin jetzt voll deep im Ranger Grill.
Ich habe auch gar keinen Bock, irgendwas anderes zu spielen.
Solange das Bock macht.
Ich meine, du hast ja immer noch die Möglichkeit,
wenn es dir zu langweilig wird, kannst du etwas anderes geben.
Nee, das ist ja der Witz.
Ich habe jetzt endlich mal wirklich einen Char gefunden,
wo ich immer Lust drauf habe.
Egal, auf was ich dann logge, denke ich mir so,
ne, die Rangers spielen so wie...
Wie das halt bei Num und bei McMorrigan zum Beispiel ist.
Soll die halt eigentlich auch gar kein Interesse haben.
Auch die neue Ladenklasse und so.
Ich werde sich halt nur für die Rewards leveln.
Aber letztendlich ist es ja gut für dich, ne?
Für mich ist es nicht schlecht, klar.
Du kannst ja dein bestes Gears Char spielen,
ohne dass es dir auf den Sack geht.
Ja, genau.
Was, Gears Sofar 4 gab es auf dem PC? Echt?
Gears Sofar 4? Echt?
Ich wusste es gar nicht.
Gears Sofar... Echt?
Oh ja, doch, na klar gab es das auf dem PC.
Aber es hat echt von Community-mäßig jetzt immer noch Expo und dann...
Stimmt, klar, das war das erste Gears, das für den PC rauskam.
Wahrscheinlich spielt das auf dem PC kaum einer.
Na ja gut, Gears Sofar 1 haben wir auch viel auf dem PC.
Also was ich spiele, ne, aber...
Ich finde, Gears Sofar merkst du an der Steuerung...
Ich sage nicht, dass man es nicht auf dem PC spielen kann.
Es ist aber im positiven Sinne an Controller angepasst.
Also es ist echt durchdacht.
So das ganze Deckungssystem und wo die Buttons auf dem Controller sind.
Also es ist echt durchdacht für Controller.
Man kann das ohne Probleme auf dem PC spielen, aber das...
Ich weiß nicht, ob das große Community hat.
Ach, mach dir jetzt ein, was ich noch fragen wollte.
Was denn?
Würdest du vielleicht...
Mit mir Monster Hunter auf der Xbox ein bisschen antesten?
Du meinst das online?
Ja.
Also was heißt online?
Ja, ich wollte mir das eh mal angucken, weil die sagen ja, dass das...
Ich weiß ja, ich hatte ja mit der Serie nie großartig was am Hut.
Ja.
Und die sagen ja, dass das das erste Monster Hunter ist, was...
Also nicht das erste Monster Hunter als Monster Hunter,
aber sie versuchen da halt auch Leute anzusprechen,
die bisher mit der Serie nichts am Hut hatten.
Ja, Monster Hunter war halt jetzt so wie Gears, weißt du?
Ja.
Das ist nie wirklich für so Allgemeinheit, so...
Ja, ich wollte mir das eh mal angucken, also das können wir ruhig machen.
Weil ich hole es mir halt nur, wenn du es jetzt vielleicht mitholen würdest,
weil ich wollte es mir eigentlich holen und ein bisschen streamen,
aber ich kenne dich halt, bei Monster Hunter spiele ich halt ein bisschen
und dann habe ich halt wirklich mehr Bock,
aber wenn wir zu zweit halt ein bisschen was machen könnten,
dann habe ich bestimmt mehr Lust darauf.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich wollte mir das eh mal angucken.
Ja.
Und dadurch, dass es halt nie auf dem PC rauskommt zeitnah,
dann wollte ich es mir halt für die Xbox holen.
Warum kommt das eigentlich auf dem...
War die PC... gab es nicht letztendlich eine Beta
und gab es die nicht auch auf dem PC?
Ja, ich weiß nie, warum das erst Ende des Jahres rauskommt für PC.
Stehe ich auch nicht.
Hä? Jetzt verstehe ich auch nicht.
Haben die... na gut, vielleicht haben die was mit Sony.
Und für mich ist es halt auch gut, wenn es auf der Xbox ist,
weil dann kann ich nämlich den BDO einen ganzen Tag craften, wirst du?
Dann kannst du AFK craften.
Ich kann den ganzen Tag AFK craften, kann streamen,
kann die Kiste und nebenbei auch BDO eingeblendet haben,
so habe ich mir das eigentlich vorgestellt.
Ich habe sogar von ein paar Overwatch-Streamern gehört,
sie wollen das jetzt spielen, weil die Q-Types in den Overwatch
sind so krass hoch, wenn du gut bist,
dass die Leute teilweise in einer Stunde oder so auf dem Match warten.
Da haben manche schon gemeint, so hey, lass Monster Hunter spielen in der Zeit.
Also das wollte ich mir eh angucken.
Ich spiele halt die Serie schon Jahre lang,
DSP damals habe ich angefangen.
Und ich kenne mich halt, wie es bei mir in der Serie ändert.
Am Anfang übertreibe ich immer übelst und baue mir alle Sets zusammen.
Und dann denke ich mir so...
Ja gut, eigentlich, gut, früher machst du es jetzt,
ein bisschen PvE stellst, wirst du?
Der Anreiz ist dann halt irgendwann nicht mehr da.
Also ich weiß halt nicht, ob mir das gefällt.
Also wir haben ja mal ganz kurz auf der Wien gespielt.
Das ist es ja, wenn du sagst, nach drei Tagen hast du keinen Bock mehr,
juck mich nicht, spiele ich einfach BDO weiter, wirst du?
Also wir haben es ja mal ganz kurz auf der Wien gespielt,
aber das war ja nur in 5 Minuten so gefühlt.
Ja genau.
Ich würde es halt wirklich nur so dann, wenn es uns beide ein bisschen gefällt,
dann können wir mal rumrennen.
Aber ich habe auch keinen Bock, das jetzt so aktiv zu spielen, wirst du?
Ich will halt beide BDO...
Wenn du nicht mehr halt fast clear machen.
Aber für ein paar... für ein paar...
Runs passt das dann schon.
So ich gucke mal, ob ich...
Ich habe wieder positives Karma.
Übrigens Leute, ich bin stolz auf euch.
Hat keiner direkt aufs negative Karma gegeiert.
Ich hätte gedacht...
Keine Angestellts gekommen.
Okay, es stellt sich klar jemand an, wenn er mich negativ sieht,
aber ich habe es ohnehin wirklich erwähnt.
Ich glaube, wenn ich was gesagt hätte,
da wären die ersten Flaps schon angerannt gekommen.
Weil es glaube ich richtig risky, oder?
Was wäre passiert, wenn ich gestorben wäre?
Ich hätte Crystals verloren, meine ganzen Jin Crystals.
Oder?
War das nicht so, dass man bei PvP tut und nichts verliert?
Nee, ich bin ja negativ gewesen.
Ich hatte minus 90 Karma, hatte ich.
Als ich den Typen gekillt habe.
Ich bin ja so einer, ich care da nicht wirklich, Schwester.
Also nie minus eine Million.
Das ist jetzt nie so geil, da care ich schon.
Aber mal so 90 Schmille oder so.
Stört mich eigentlich eher weniger.
Äh, 90.000.
Das macht Bock.
Sinnloser Kreisel-Crypt.
Also finde ich zumindest, mir macht es Bock hier.
Ah, das ist nice.
Und es gibt halt Geld.
Also es macht halt auch irgendwo ein bisschen Sinn.
Vor allem bist du nicht so schnell zugemüllt mit Loot,
wenn du das direkt zählen kannst im Marketplace.
Ja, genau.
Das ist eigentlich der größte Anreiz zu Gruppen fast schon.
Dass es automatisch im Marketplace gesellt wird.
Das hat gerade einer im Chat gefragt.
Aber ich musste mal raussuchen.
Wollt ihr beide nicht mal wieder Udo spielen?
Geil.
Uno, Uno.
Die gleichen Scheißidee.
Das war aber best.
Was für dumme Videos wir früher gemacht haben, oder Max?
Muss noch die Silvana mal überreden.
Lass mal wieder Uno spielen.
Auf meinem alten Handy hatte ich noch ihre Telefonnummer.
Die ist auf Twitter am Start.
Echt?
Ja, die würden wir erreichen.
Geil.
Silvansrohr.
Das müssen wir echt machen.
Mittlerweile kannst du auch 360-Spieler auf der One spielen.
Du kannst sogar Uno drauf spielen wahrscheinlich.
Ich glaube, Uno gibt es doch ganz normal zum runterladen, oder?
Davon abgesehen, es gibt wahrscheinlich von Uno gefühlt 500 Versionen auf der Konsole.
Gibt es auch die Black Desert in dich?
Weißt du, da sind die Uno-Karten, dann haben wir Black Spirit drauf.
Da ist der rote Ranger-Krill zum Uno.
Ja, das wäre natürlich nice.
Wobei das Ranger-Kill, das ist ja Asiagame.
Die machen ja dann nicht Uno, die müssen eher Uno.
So weißt du.
Wo ist das?
Ach, da am Strand ist es.
Das ist da PvP, Gem-Loss, Explos.
Schön, für so einen Randy, schön fast meine ganzen Crystals.
Aber ich bin immer schnell getriggert, Leute.
Ich bin immer schnell getriggert.
Wenn es auch so abläuft wie gerade, weißt du.
Wenn er schon geritten ist, dann ist er kurz angehalten, hat geguckt.
Dann hat er sich gedacht, so, jetzt wickse ich da mit rein.
Genau so, wie er sich das gedacht hat.
Ja, wie wirklich?
Übrigens, bei mir schreibt gerade einer im Chat Erklärungen, warum Monster Hunter auf dem PC so spät kommt.
Sagt er, dass Entwicklerstudio möchte das Spiel bestmöglich optimieren für den PC
und hatten bis jetzt anscheinend dort keine Erfahrungen von Portierung.
Das wäre eine Erklärung, die finde ich gar nicht mal so übel, wenn das so ist.
Die ist sogar sehr gut.
Das ist auch schlüssig irgendwie, wenn man hauptsächlich Konsolengames bisher gemacht hat.
Weil ich mir halt denke, so der Unterschied von der Xbox One und der PS4 zu einem PC.
Also so große Unterschied ist es jetzt nicht mehr.
Ich denke quasi, ja, dieses ganze Controlling denn.
Ja, das stimmt, das hast du recht.
Ja, Input, Controller, Zeug.
Ja, das kann gut sein.
Also ich weiß nie, wie du Monster Hunter mit WASD oder nicht spielen willst.
Du weißt ja, wie die moveen.
Ich kann mich noch so dunkel dran erinnern, ja.
Klubbe voll schwer.
Ich meine, was ja nicht einen davon abhalten würde, dass man den Controller an den PC stöpselt.
Ja, natürlich, aber dann kann ich ja gleich die Konsole spielen, so ungefähr.
Ja, das sieht doch besser aus. Ich finde, so Sachen wie Assassin's Creed und sowas finde ich am besten auf dem PC mit Controller.
Weil du hast halt...
Du hast halt...
Die geile Grafik.
Genau, es sieht geil aus.
Wenn man schon einen PC hat, der was kann, dann wäre es auch bescheuert, wenn man es nicht macht.
So, und dann mit dem Controller dran und da hast du noch die beste Steuerung.
Ich meine, wir können auch noch bis Ende des Jahres warten. Ich muss das jetzt wie gleich spielen.
Ja, wir können ja mal gucken. Ich muss eh erstmal dann eins, zwei Reviews angucken.
Wir streiten uns wahrscheinlich wieder über die Waffe.
Echt? Warum? Haben wir uns schon über die Waffe gestretten?
Ne, ne wirklich, aber du bist doch auch so Support.
Ach du meinst, wer Support spielen darf.
Ja genau, weil ich spiele ja meistens Warhorn, das Kriegshorn, wo du so Musik mit machst.
Buff.
Und dann kannst du halt buffen, Leute buffen, das spiele ich meistens.
Das ist die Hottemade am Start.
Ja.
Warum?
Hottemade.
Hottig Grill-Made.
Und das gestellste Ranger Grill.
Ich hab übrigens mein Pferd hier drüben geparkt, das ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Weißt ja nie, wo da eins steht.
Oh, am Standard-Sausensport steht das.
Da in der Mitte.
Also unten.
Ja, da wo man, weißt du an dieser Mauer am Sausensport, da wo man immer sein Zeug anstellt.
Wo bist denn du? Ach, da hinten.
Ja, ich bin gerade kurz beim Pferd gewesen.
Ich könnte ja auch einfach mal Qcanceln für Mana statt immer noch...
Und ich könnte auch mal ein bisschen mehr meinen Buff anmachen.
Ja, ich bin wieder, ich bin halt Ranger so voll der suboptimale Rumspiel-Grinder.
Ist ja, wenn ich lower einen Mana gehe, dann werfe ich mir einen Pott, brauch ich gar nicht.
Guck mal, ich kann direkt hier reincanceln, bin instant wieder voll.
Macht gar keinen Sinn überhaupt mit Mana-Ports hier zu spielen.
Da, da hat man, bei einer Sache hat sie voll recht, das Problem kenne ich als Wizard echt nicht.
Ja.
Ich dash rein, hab volles Mana, so.
Zack, voll.
Easy.
Weißt du was ich gemerkt hab?
Ich hab jetzt ja 14 Tage nicht gestreamt.
Mhm.
Und davor hatte ich immer so 100, 120 teilweise.
Und wenn du eine Weile nicht gestreamt hast, müssen dich die Leute erst mal dran gewöhnen, dass du wieder am streamen bist.
Echt?
Ja.
Oder aber die Zeit ist scheiße.
Also bei mir ist es auch mal richtig gruselig, ne?
Wieso?
Ich mach mal einen Stream an, aber das ist doch cool, ich meine, ich spiele ja auch jetzt schon, ich streame das ja auch schon zwei Jahre.
Mach mal einen Stream an, also ich drücke auf den Knopf, ne?
Ist der instant erste Chat-Nachricht.
Und dann geht mein Chat halt hallo.
Ja, das ist auch, das finde ich immer geil.
Ich denke so, what the fuck?
Das finde ich immer geil, ja.
Hast du Leute, die...
Wieso?
Stream angemacht?
Hallo?
Wieso?
Das ist wie auf YouTube wurde früher gesagt, dass du Ammo-Box-Camper, weißt du?
Ja.
Ach, ich meine, ich find's ja geil.
Ja, nee.
Das ist ja keine Beschwerde, aber ich find das irgendwie lustig, so.
Ja.
Kommst auch leider dann...
Hallo?
Instant.
Du hast wirklich, es ist wirklich instant, ne, das ist nicht eine Minute später, sondern
Stream läuft, sobald die Werbung geladen ist.
Ja, das habe ich aber auch.
Das habe ich aber auch.
Also, da erinnert mich immer, wie die Leute so schnell am Start sind.
Ja.
Boah, ich hab S.
Das neue Knowledge-System finde ich echt nicht schlecht.
Das neue Knowledge-System?
Klar, du bestätigst einfach Mops und kriegst irgendwann S.
Ach so?
Das heißt, man muss das mit dem Resetten gar nicht machen?
Du kriegst jedes Mal, kriegst du einen neuen Grade.
Also, dieses komische Reset-Zeug braucht man jetzt gar nicht mehr?
Nee, musst du ihn immer machen.
Boah, deswegen habe ich vorhin auch S gekriegt vor dem Mob.
Ja.
Ist recht cool.
Das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, klar, ich hab irgendwie...
Da können sich jetzt aber alle drüber aufregen, die vorher den S-Grind gemacht haben.
Ja, eben.
Ich habe halt Energy reingesteckt und Loyalties auch für die Tränke.
Aber who cares, man?
Ist doch nicht schlecht.
Bundessystem, man.
Also, ich finde es...
Und ich habe bestimmt, keine Ahnung, 20k Loyalties hier in den scheiß Tränke reingesteckt,
wenn nicht sogar mehr.
Boah, in serious, Max.
Streamst du wieder regelmäßiger?
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Ich muss jetzt ja wieder arbeiten, das ist das Problem.
Das war echt, das war so geil im Dezember, ne?
Wo ich den Monat frei hatte.
Ich tue dich daran, ey.
Stimmt, bei dir war es ja noch...
Bei dir war es ja gar nicht...
Du, du warst ja...
Ich war durch arbeiten.
Ja.
Deshalb hatte ich die Woche jetzt Urlaub.
Oh nee, du musst nächste Woche wieder aus.
Ich sag nichts.
Ich dachte, das ging mir so auf den Sack selbst.
Nö, das stört mich nicht.
Ich musste bloß mal...
Ich musste bloß mal den Reset-Knopf drücken.
Ich war irgendwie getriggert auf Arbeit.
Ist nicht so, dass ich keinen Bock hatte.
Aber mich hat das...
Weißt du, wenn du so übelst genervt bist von allen Sachen?
Von allem, ja.
Obwohl es gar keinen Grund gibt.
Und da weiß ich immer, dass ich einfach mal eine Woche Urlaub brauche.
Und mal Brain-Afka irgendwie nichts machen muss.
Dann geht es wieder.
Sonst bin ich nicht nur, sonst bin ich mad.
Nächste Woche freue ich mich schon wieder auf Arbeit.
Ja, ich muss sagen, es ist bei mir ja auch nicht so, dass ich keinen Bock auf die Arbeit an sich hatte.
Ich habe dann immer nach so langer Zeit Urlaub einfach keinen Bock hinzugehen.
Und wenn ich dann hingehe und dann da bin, dann geht es eigentlich.
Dann sag ich mir, ja gut, soll alles in Ordnung.
Meine Woche geht halt immer chillig los mit montags meinen vier Stunden da.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es durchgehalten habe früher.
Fünf Tage die Woche.
Fünf Tage?
Ich weiß...
Ich gehe ja fünf Tage, aber dafür halt montag nur von 13 bis 17 Uhr.
Ich kann das auch nicht.
Also irgendwie ein ganzes bisschen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das Leute immer machen.
Was arbeitet ihr denn?
Ich mache Rezeption und Buchhaltung und Warenbestellung und so Vertretertermine und alles.
Mitarbeiterorganisation in einem...
...drei Etagen Friseurgeschäft.
Ja, jetzt bist du dran.
Ich bin...
Es ist immer schwierig.
Ich tue mir echt schön das zu umschreiben, aber ich sage mal so ganz simpel gesagt,
ich arbeite in einem Rechenzentrum, so in der Richtung könnte man das eigentlich sagen,
wobei ich wenig mit Servern zu tun habe.
In der IT...
Sagen wir mal, es ist zwar keine Bank, wo ich arbeite, aber sagen wir mal in der IT von einer Bank.
Es ist sehr ähnlich zu einer Bank.
Ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um unsere Softwareverwaltung und sowas.
Du bist ein richtiger Bürohengst geworden, ey.
Aber mir ist es so schlimm.
Es ist so schlimm mittlerweile, ne.
Du sitzt auf der Arbeit rum, dann sitzt du daheim rum, machst irgendwelche YouTube-Geschichten.
Ich bin so viel vorm Rechner, das ist einfach nicht normal.
Das Einzige, was ich jetzt mache, ist morgens ein bisschen früher aussteigen aus dem Zug
und auf die Arbeit laufen und zurück mittags.
Aber ansonsten...
Ey, nice.
Nice, du.
Hast du S-Rank?
Ne, A-plus, aber danach kommt S.
Ach, das ist gar nicht mehr random, du kriegst einfach...
Ne, du kriegst einfach, wenn du A startest und meine...
Also du kriegst random, das ist schon den ersten zugewiesen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt immer direkt mit C startet und dann geht es immer weiter runter.
Wenn du A kriegst, kriegst du als nächstes dann...
Also wenn du A kriegst, kriegst du als nächstes A-plus und dann kommt schon S.
Oh, das ist nice.
Dafür dauert es jetzt länger, bis du was kriegst.
Anscheinend.
Ich meine, ich glaube hier jetzt schon ewig Mops hier mit dir und ich habe jetzt einen Mob aufgerankt schon.
Vielleicht hast du ja schon S.
Ja, bei dem einen Mob habe ich S.
Aber hier gibt es ja mehrere Mops.
Müsste eigentlich schon noch ein bisschen...
Echt, meinst du, das sind bloß die Großen und die Kleinen?
Und was sind die anderen? Warte kurz.
Gladiator, Gladiator.
Nee, Armor.
Meistens sind Gladiator.
Dann gibt es eh mit der Axt und dem Schneiper.
Ja, hier gibt es doch noch mehr Gladiator.
Ja, Hitze Schneiper.
Das war links hier, Bad Company.
Ja.
Die geilen Hitze Schneiper.
Alter, wie wir die Beta gesuchtet haben.
Ich zumindest.
Das war geil.
Walparaiso.
Ich habe das so gesuchtet, man.
Nee, Port Walder ist das beste Map.
Ja.
Das hat mir richtig Bock gemacht.
Das war auch das einzige Battlefield, was ich gut fand.
Battlefield 3 war auch gut.
Das hat mich richtig gesuchtet, man.
Battlefield 3 war auch gut. Ich weiß, das war jetzt nicht so dein Fall.
Nee.
Weil ich glaube, trotzdem, wenn du es mehr gespielt hättest,
hättest du es auch geil gefunden.
Nee.
Da ging es los mit riesen Monster,
3.000 Maps und zu viele Fahrzeugstelle.
Ich hasse Fahrzeugstelle.
Also es ging in Battlefield 3 eigentlich.
Wo es richtig schlimm war, Fahrzeugstelle,
es waren die Maps in Battlefield 4.
Alter, hast du, kennst du,
hast du eigentlich das Gewicht schon gehört,
dass Bad Company 3 in Entwicklung ist?
Ja, das letzte schon mal im Stream erzählt,
aber
juckt mich halt nicht so.
Ich meine, wer weiß, wann das rauskommt,
zu irgendwann 2019 oder so.
Ja.
Das ist ja den ancient Shooter, den ich mir
wiederholen werde. Irgendwann ist halt Gears
sofort das neue dann.
Es war ansonsten die ganzen Serien,
die anderen, die ich spiele einfach nicht mehr.
Aber Gears macht mir eigentlich immer Bock.
Weil Gears ist halt das Problem, das musst du halt
nicht trainieren, wenn du bashen willst.
Das kannst du dir einfach so einlegen und wie bei COD
zum Beispiel einfach spielst du ein paar
Runden, guckst mal so was, was
läuft, weißt du, und machst halt ein paar
Kills. Geht ja jetzt nicht gleich darum
eine Moab zu machen.
Aber du kannst halt schon irgendwie spielen,
aber bei Gears ist es so, wenn du halt
eine Weile nicht gespielt hast, du sackst so hart,
du machst gar keine Ingenie. Ich hab ja mal ein paar
Turnier-Matches geguckt
von Gears 8.
Die bewegen sich ja gar nicht
auf die Map, wie es gedacht ist,
sondern die sind ja nur von wann zu wann.
Ich war immer eine Zeit echt
gut damit.
Also ich war immer eine Zeit lang
echt nicht schlecht.
Aber es ist halt das Problem,
das kannst du eben näher,
das musst du halt an Main das geben.
Sonst geht halt nichts bei Gears.
Gears.
Danke fürs Follow übrigens.
Thank you follow, thank you follow.
Auch die Koreaner immer.
Ist das eigentlich viele koreanische Streamer?
Schon, ja.
Seit dieses Afrika,
oder wie das Ding heißt.
Ja, das ist ja eine Kackseite.
Ah, gibt es das gar nicht mehr?
Nee, die hatten ja irgendwelche Scheiße gemacht
mit ihren Payouts
für die Streamer und dann
sind ganz viele halt auf Twitch gewechselt.
Ach, deswegen. Okay, ich hab mich schon
gewundert, weil es gibt auch ein paar
Overwatch-Pros, ne? Die haben
früher auf irgendeiner anderen Seite, ich glaube, auf diesem
Afrika gestreamt. Und die sind jetzt auf
Twitch am Start. Was machen die auf einmal?
Also, ich weiß nicht, ich hab schon lange nicht mehr
geguckt, weil früher hab ich dort wirklich so
koreanisches Zeug, hab ich sogar dort geguckt.
Ich hab sogar mehr
da geguckt als Twitch.
Also, das ist schon 10 Jahre her, wirst du?
Aber die ganze
Zauberfläche war so auch so. Das ist
kacke. Also
die ganzen Seiten sind übelst kacke.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was die da machen. Die müssen sich doch einfach nur abgucken,
wie es gut funktioniert.
Aber die Bedienung von
YouTube wird auch.
Nee, nicht Battlefield, Battle Royale,
also PUBG, PUBG-Klonen soll ich machen.
Welches Spiel ich ganz
interessant finde, ist das, wo man so
bauen kann. Ist das Fortnite
oder so? Ja.
Das find ich interessant.
Wenn ich nicht so viel BDO suchte, hätte ich mir das
bestimmt mal angeguckt.
Fortnite wird ja auch von Leuten gemacht, die wissen, wie es geht.
Aber dieses
PUBG oder PUBG oder wie man das
so immer jetzt ausspricht,
das spricht mich gar nicht an, weil es sinnloses
Rumgestellte ist.
Also nicht sinnlos, aber du weißt ja, du kennst ja,
wie ich spiele. Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst.
Dann kann ich nie über die Map flitzen und reinraschen.
Ich find das witzig, dass du grad Pupke sagst.
Das ist vom gleichen Hersteller wie
Gears zuvor.
Ja, ja, das weiß ich. Aber es ist trotzdem schlecht.
Rumgestellte und Gears ist
ist Gerusher. Gears ist ja kein
Gestellte. Ja, Fortnite ist
Fortnite ist im Vergleich zu Pupke, aber
glaub ich ein bisschen schneller. Also er kämpft
nicht gar so viel in Häusern rum und so.
Du kannst doch coole Aktionen machen, finde ich.
Du kannst, du kannst an, du kannst wohl irgendwie,
wenn du an so einer Wand bist, kannst du dir dann
eine Treppe hochbauen und sowas.
Also wenn ich Streams gucke mal
ab und zu von Battle Royale, da gucke ich ehrlich gesagt
auch viel lieber Fortnite-Streams anstatt
Pupke. Pupke finde ich
übelst langweilig zu gucken.
Find ich auch. Du stellst
immer, außer bei, außer bei hier
Dinge ins Cursions, da guck ich halt manchmal.
Na?
Wer ist der denn? Der mit dem Schnauzer?
Disre, ähm
Disrespect. Ja.
Den guckst du aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht
wegen Pupke, sondern einfach
wegen dem Typ.
Aber Pupke ist halt echt so.
Guck, Pupke spielt halt so. Du
läufst dann da nicht rein, du stehst jetzt hier so.
Stehst jetzt hier so.
Stehst du da rum und strafst von links
nach rechts, von links nach rechts.
Na ja, halt so ein ziemlich stelltes Game.
Wo ist er? Wir machen jetzt Battle Royale. Wo ist er? Wir machen jetzt Pupke.
Machen wir Pupke.
Aber erstmal haltest du 20 Minuten irgendwo rum.
Wie kniet man sich nochmal hin?
In BDO?
Äh...
Q? Nee. Doch, doch.
Q.
So. Pupke.
Leute.
Es wird gestellt.
Du hast mich schon outplayed, Max. Nee, ich bin doch hier.
Guck mal, ich schleiche noch.
So geht das. Oh krass, du bist noch gestellt, ne? Du bist gekannt.
Das ist ein richtig krasser Tanner.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Bäm.
Schreckt.
20 Minuten rumgestellt, instantly bashed.
Oder noch besser
weggesniped, so von drei Kilometer aus einem Haus,
wo du mich nicht sehen konntest.
It's bad. Aber es ist taktisch,
Max.
Es ist tatsächlich nicht...
Ich weiß, du meinst es nicht, aber es ist tatsächlich
taktisch. Aber ich finde, es ist...
Also weißt du, es ist ein Unterschied,
ähm, wenn du halt,
wenn du taktisch spielen musst,
in Form von, du musst halt permanent
deine Moves überdenken, weil
der Gegner moved, aber in Pupke ist es halt so,
ähm, man wartet
sich gegenseitig aus, so weißt du?
Wer moved hat gelitten, so.
Ich mag's einfach nicht. Ich sag ja nicht, dass es
schlecht ist und dass keiner spielen sollte.
Aber der Hype ist so vorbei,
oder?
So ein bisschen, oder ist der noch zu richtig krass?
Es ist jetzt nicht mehr der Hype,
dass jeder alle paar Minuten von Pupke
spricht, aber wenn du mal
Zuschauerzahlen und so anguckst, ist es
immer noch extrem gut.
Ich mein, wann hat es es schon mal gegeben,
dass ein neues Game rauskommt und das unter,
das quasi permanent in den Top
3 auf Twitch ist?
Ich muss jetzt gerade mal gucken, wo das gerade ist.
Schauen wir mal Twitch.
Ich guck mal,
wo Pupke gerade ist.
Okay, Platz 4. 197.000
Spieler, äh,
Zuschauer. Das ist schon krass, oder?
Einfach mal aus dem Nichts, so.
Guckst du Overwatch League, wenn
Dallas spielt? Ja, mach ich.
Sofern es halt geht.
Nachts um 3.
Ja, oh Blizzard,
die Zeiten. Aber heute,
ne? Heute, wo man gucken könnte,
haben sie es so gelegt,
dass es jetzt gerade parallel läuft.
Ja.
Aber heute, ne? Heute,
wo man gucken könnte,
haben sie es so gelegt, dass es jetzt gerade parallel läuft,
wo wir hier streben.
Okay.
Aber das läuft ja immer in ein paar Stunden, insofern krieg ich noch
ein paar Games mit nachher.
Wenn nicht, ist es auch nicht so schlimm.
Ich glaub, heute spielt keiner,
der mich groß interessiert.
So, mal an beide Chats. Die Frage
hat zwar mit BDO auch nichts zu tun.
Aber ich glaube, es geht um Overwatch League.
Bei mir reagiert niemand.
Alle daunen. Ne, das dauert ja ein bisschen.
Bis es zum Chat kommt.
Also bei mir schreiben wir es die ersten, ja.
Ja gut, bei dir ist es ja klar auf dem Chat.
Eigentlich hab ich auch schon öfters Overwatch gestreamt.
LOL Overwatch, komm, das ist der erste bei dir.
LOL Overwatch.
Overwatch.
Overwatch E-Sport, null.
Also ganz ehrlich, bevor ich mir
Hearthstone E-Sport angucke, guck ich mir lieber
Overwatch E-Sport an.
Hearthstone E-Sport ist ja auch wirklich...
Das ist Resident Sleeper, ist das.
Hearthstone E-Sport.
Vor allem je nach Deck ist das RNG
halt...
Da ist das RNG hier beim Craft
nix dagegen.
Nee, nee, ich finde es gar nicht mal so, teilweise
je nach Deck ist es mal gar nicht so RNG.
Also so krass.
Also ich finde es ist krasser als bei
anderen Card Games irgendwie, weil du hast
bei Hearthstone hast du
so viele...
Weißt du, du hast natürlich in jedem Kartenspiel
random, weil du nicht weißt, was du ziehst.
Das ist ja schon mal klar. Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal Grundsätzlich.
Aber gut, du kannst so beeinflussen, zum Beispiel Magic.
Kannst du die Deck
so aufbauen, dass du mit Card
Searchern halt hier
deine komplette Combo zusammenbauen kannst und
theoretisch, wenn du eine gute
Starthand hast, ist das Game schon in der ersten Runde gewinnt.
Ja, du hast ja bei Yu-Gi-Oh! auch Karten,
wo du dann schneller Karten ziehen kannst und so.
Aber was du bei Hearthstone halt in Massen
hast, sind Karten, die ja noch so Random
Effekte haben. Weißt du,
da hat er gefühlt jede Karte irgendwie einen Random
Effekt. Und das nimmt
dann ganz abgedrehte Sachen an.
Ich hab letztens irgendein Game
gesehen, da hat er irgendwie ein Legendary
gehabt, dadurch hat er zufällig dann
andere Karten gezogen und davon dann irgendwie
eine fünfte Chance, dass dann eine besondere
Karte rauskommt und hier hat er dann wieder einen Effekt
und so. Das war ganz wir. Da hast du überhaupt nicht mal durchgeklickt,
was da eigentlich passiert.
Da wäre gerade bei
Paradienst, was ich ein bisschen
schade finde, ist,
dass
Paragon
so
untergegangen ist.
Was ist Paragon? Das ist das von Epic.
Das von Epic, also das von
Leuten, die auf Gears of War gemacht haben.
Und Fortnite.
Ich glaube, du hast das sogar gespielt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das unter...
Das ist doch noch gar nicht raus.
Oder? Ich glaube, das ist noch gar nicht raus, richtig? Das ist Beta
noch. Naja, was heißt
Beta?
Ist das immer noch Beta? Ich glaube schon.
Übrigens, wir werden gerade geflamt
im Chat. Wenn man sich mit
Hearthstone beschäftigt, ist das nicht Residenz
Liefer. Und der RNG-Anteil ist gar
nicht mal so krass, weil
seit drei Jahren dieselben 200 Spieler
von 50 Millionen in Top 200 sind.
Also, wenn man keine Ahnung hat,
vorsichtig sein.
Bei Hearthstone ist es... Das stimmt
schon. Er hat ja schon recht.
Du kannst das schon beeinflussen, vor allem
wenn du es über die Menge der Games siehst.
Das ist schon richtig.
Also, über die Menge, wenn du viele Spiele spielst,
wirst du trotzdem der Bessere letztendlich
gewinnen. Das ist klar.
Ich sage ja, es ist nicht RNG. Flamed den Max
nämlich. Der hat gesagt, es ist RNG.
Aber wenn man die einzelnen Partien betrachtet,
ist Hearthstone mega RNG.
Das siehst du auch teilweise, dass
wenn du irgendwelche... Moment, wo renn ich denn überhaupt
hin gerade?
Wenn du manchmal gute Spieler...
Wenn du Streams dir anguckst von guten Spielern,
die dann gegen die übelsten Plaps losen, weil
sie einfach Pech haben. Das ist aber halt nur, wenn
man das einzelne Game betrachtet. Über die Menge
der Games ist klar, dass dann
die bessere Zusammenstellung und die
besseren Spieler, die halt dann auch
ein bisschen überlegen können, wie sind die Chancen
so, dann öfters richtig liegen. Das ist klar.
Aber ich finde trotzdem, dass so Sachen wie Yu-Gi-Oh!
fand ich bei weitem nicht so RNG
mäßig wie Hearthstone. Aber es kann auch
durchaus sein, weil ich Hearthstone nicht viel gespielt habe.
No offense.
Lul.
Wo ist denn der kleine Wisthard?
Der ist am Pferd. Alter, bist du da hinten?
Och Max! Was denn?
Stell dir dein Pferd mit am Spot ab.
Ich hab doch gesagt, das steht am Sausenspot.
Ich muss das erst mal herbringen.
Ich dachte, das war ein Witz. Nein!
Das steht am Sausenspot. Ich guck grad auf die Map
und seh dich da hinten, ey.
Egal.
Ich komm jetzt vor, gerettet.
Das war kein Witz.
Das steht da wirklich rauf.
Ach ja, weil du grad gesagt hast,
ach nee, du hast Paragon gesagt, ne?
Ich meinte, ich meinte hier
Paladins.
Paladins kriegt jetzt
einen Battle Royale-Modus.
Ja, ja.
Also Paladins ist ja das, wo alle immer sagen,
aufhauen wir uns Klon, aufhauen wir uns Klon, dazu
sag ich jetzt mal nichts, aber
jetzt krieg ich einen Battle Royale-Modus. Aber wo stellt man hier jetzt
seinen Gaul genau hin?
Ja, komm zu mir. Moment.
Wo bist du denn?
Bei hinten.
Ja, stells hier unten hin.
Ah.
Oh.
Warte, ich...
Ey, ich kann mich jetzt, jetzt kann ich mich
nicht bewegen, weil ich überladen bin, ey.
Ah.
Wizzard, der Wizzard,
Wizzard, kannst du klettern?
Kleine Wurblos, Alter.
Alter.
Ruf doch...
Stell dich hier hin, Max.
Ich mach jetzt mal...
Die Fässer kaputt.
Nein, WTF, stell dich doch hier hin.
Ruf einfach dein Pferd.
Ich muss erstmal aus dem
Wasser raus, ey.
Der Highspeed-Wurpler, guck mal, wie er abgeht.
Vor allem der Tauch,
der wird da gleich ertrinken.
Ja, einfach hier hinstellen.
Alter, wie er schwimmt.
Einmal mit Profis.
Hier, wenn du dich hier hinstellst, kannst du dein Pferd
rufen, ohne dass es rippt.
Okay.
Alles.
Also, du müsst dich schon in die Mitte stellen,
nicht, dass es gleich im Wasser ist.
Normalerweise müsste es runterkommen.
Oder?
Ja.
Genau, jetzt kannst du dein Loot...
Ist das geklebt?
Doch, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt.
WTF?
Pferd!
Wo ist es hin?
Da ist es hier, hier ist es.
Ich sehe es nicht.
Ich krieg nicht alles ins Pferd rein.
Das schwerste ins Pferd rein.
Achso, siehst du, das ist halt, wenn man keine Mates hat.
Ja.
Kommt man hier überhaupt noch
hoch wieder?
So, ich schmeiß jetzt die Fässer weg.
Was darf man sonst machen?
Kann man jetzt so ein bisschen
Crying-Action machen?
Hier müsste man eigentlich
wieder hochkommen.
Ich bin ja außen hochgegangen. Also, ich habe
mein Pferd halt hier stehen.
Der Wubbler wird ausgedacht.
So, weiter geht's.
Wo bist du denn?
Komm zu dir.
Ja.
Mach mal meine geile Daily an.
Das könnt ihr mal auch mal machen.
Das mach ich nie irgendwie.
Oh, ich muss wieder Black Spirit
Buff holen.
Lul.
Ist hier
eigentlich Leute gute Skill-Exp?
In dem Spot.
Oh, ich muss snipen, glaube ich.
Oh.
Kannste nicht durch die Lappen gehen lassen.
Oh nein, die sind
schon drin.
Nein, kann ich nicht.
Ich glaube, ich habe hier nur 6 Mille, wenn ich
Markplatz-Mate benutze.
Ja, RIP.
Was wolltest du?
Oregon-Schuhe.
Was sind das?
Wie, sind meine Masken-Schuhe
outdated jetzt?
Nein, wirklich.
Ich würde sagen, das ist das einzige Mal hier selbst
Item geholt von dem Boss.
Mehr die Ardan bei Oregon Boots.
Was, mehr?
Das wäre jetzt auch nicht so krass, wenn ich jetzt habe.
Also, das wäre schon nice, weil ich
switchen will, aber...
Ist das jetzt eher PvP-mäßig, die Boots?
Nein, auch nicht. Es kommt immer auf Setup
an. Also, manche Klassen sind halt mega stark
damit, wie bei Kyren und
Dingens. Ranger ist für mich
bloß so ein bisschen Prediction,
weil ich halt null Evasion spiele.
Obwohl ich halt einen
Z-Buff habe.
Aber ich denke mir in meinem
Kleinhirn,
dass mit einem
mit einem
Oregon Schuhe plus Protection Stone
plus noch irgendwas, die AR
geswitcht ist, ich
teilweise gegen so DKs
ein bisschen bessere Matchups habe.
Als jetzt mit Full Evasion.
Also, für mich ist das erstmal wurscht.
Ja.
Zumal bei unserem, bei meinem
Snipe Glück, irgendwann.
Dritter Snipe habe ich es dann. Ja.
Eigentlich habe ich
bis jetzt doch gar nicht so falsch gelegen.
Die Leute haben ja auch immer gelacht mit
was ich von zwei, drei Monaten
gesagt habe. Ja, die AR-Meter wird bestimmt
kommen. Ah, Quatsch, Quatsch.
Du guckst hier dir an, wie
sie alle mit der AR rumrennen. Zumindest auf den,
wo es richtig gut geht. Damit, damit
erzählen, dass man ergeblich keine
Ahnung hat, ist ja überall so.
Das ist auch unter Videos
immer, wenn du irgendwelche Leute hast.
Vor allem, wenn es um irgendwelche, sogar noch Sachen
geht, die du einfach belegen kannst, um irgendwelche
technischen Sachen oder so, hast du immer
Instantly Leute am Start, die dann so anfangen
so nach dem Motto, oha, oha, Max,
da musst du dich besser informieren. Das ist nicht
korrekt. Und wenn du sie dann fragst, ja, was
kommt da nicht, dann kommt entweder nichts
oder eben eine bescheuerte Antwort.
Ja gut, das ist halt nur Spekulation
am Ende, jetzt in BDO zum Beispiel,
aber so ein gewisser,
so ein großes gewisses, wenn du ein
gewisses Grundverständnis hast, sag ich
mal so vom,
von den Items und von dem
Spiel an sich,
dann kann man schon mal was testen,
selbst wenn jetzt zum Beispiel die eigene Klasse
mit der jetzt nie so gut scale.
Also ich merke zum Beispiel
den krassesten Unterschied
zwischen vorher meinem HP-Pool
mit 2800
und jetzt mit meinem
HP-Pool von
gebufft fast 4k.
Das nimmt mir weiter Unterschied.
Kann das Ranger-Krill
tanken?
Nee, das nee, aber...
Ich frag gerade an deinem Chat, wie ich Mario Odyssey
fand.
Ich hab Mario Odyssey,
also ich hab's gespielt,
aber ich hab's nicht weit gespielt und gar nicht
weil's schlecht ist, sondern weil ich die ganze Zeit
irgendwie nicht zukomme. Aber das, was ich bisher
gespielt hab, fand ich extrem geil.
Also extrem abwechslungsreich
und zum ersten Mal
ist es auch so ein bisschen
so Fanservice in Nintendo Games.
Bei Nintendo Games hatte ich bisher immer das Gefühl,
die machen alles, dass die Fans es nicht
geil finden, immer so. Weißt du, wie ich meine?
Also die machen die Games geil vom Gameplay her
und so, da kannst du bei Nintendo nie was sagen.
Aber so ein bisschen Richtung
Fanservice hat Nintendo ja,
haben sie ja nie gemacht, also sprich
du hattest dann selten Sachen, die du so
wiedererkannt hast oder Sachen, die du geil findest.
So und jetzt in Mario Odyssey
ist da wirklich ganz viel Zeug drin.
Hab ich mir ja nie erholt,
aber ich hab ja auch keine Switch. Die erste
Konsole, die ich mir in meinem Leben nie gekauft hab,
ist richtig krass. Ich weiß nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Der Asia Grind
hat mich komplett übernommen.
Du bist voll
anders geworden.
Aber im Prinzip, ne, Max, was ist
denn auch immer gewesen? Wir haben uns die ganzen
Konsole immer geholt, ein Spiel und
dann standen sie rum. Außer die
360. 360 haben wir richtig
gesuchtet. 360 hatten wir ja irgendwie,
ich hab hier, muss ich mal umdrehen hier, ich hab's ja hier
mittlerweile total sinnlos
eigentlich, ne. Ich hab mir damals, als wir
hier umgezogen sind, extra für die
PS3 und 360 Spiele für so ein
Regal geholt, einfach weil ich's geil fand und wie
das aussieht mit den DVDs
und so. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel
das sind, ey, keine Ahnung,
60, 70 oder so,
das ist sau viel, ey.
Aber da haben wir uns auch noch gegenseitig per Post
Spiele geschickt, damit wir GS machen.
Weißt, kennst du noch dieses
komische Avatar-Spiel?
Das Avatar, wo man in 5 Minuten 1.000
GS gemacht hat. 1.000 GS oder 1.250
GS oder so.
Ja. Ja.
Das Game, das war halt
übel Scheiße, ja, aber die Leute,
die haben das Game
dann sogar später auf eBay
und so gehandelt. Also das Game, das
war dann was wert und nur
weil du damit einfach Xbox
Gamerscore machen kannst.
Das haben sie so verkackt auf der
Xbox One. Dieses ganze Freundessystem
Gamerscore und sonst was. Weißt du,
es gab damals Leute, die
haben quasi anstatt BDO zu
grinden, haben die Microsoft Points gegrindet.
Die haben jedes Scheißgame übelst durchgegrindet,
um 1.000 GS zu machen.
Und so was. Und heute
juckt GS doch gar kein mehr.
Wie viel GS du auf deinem Account hast.
Hier steht gerade ein
riesen Wall of Text, ich muss mir das mal kurz
durchlesen beziehungsweise vorlesen, er steht.
Zumindest hattest du mit deinem
As... Achso.
Zumindest hattest du mit deinem Asula Kram richtig
reguliert, der Nopal Camper letztens
KR2 gezeigt, bestand, dass das Asula Set
abgegradet. Ja gut, aber das war irgendwie obvious,
dass da noch was passiert.
Ich hätte zwar nie gedacht, dass man upgraden
kann und die Upgrades sind auch nie wirklich groß.
Deshalb habe ich mir
ja meine ganzen Ketten und so aufgehoben,
aber Mattern tut das nie wirklich.
Ich hätte halt gedacht, man kann so Trade-Ins
machen, was weiß ich. Drei Amus
für einen Ring zum
Beispiel, dass man die untereinander
praktisch eintauschen kann
für das jeweilige Teil, um es noch einfacher
zu machen. Mit dem Upgrade ist aber schon
ganz witzig.
Ich glaube eh ein Schaden. Ach man kann
das Upgraden oder was?
Ja, das Asula Zeug. Aber es kommt glaube
nie mehr, nie wirklich was dazu.
Ich glaube es kommt DP dazu,
es kommt glaube ich kein AP dazu, sondern nur DP
und ich glaube Akku. Ich weiß aber nicht
mehr was genau.
Irgendwas ist aber nicht. Ich meine das ist jetzt schon ziemlich
gut. Oh wow krass.
Ich meine das ist ja jetzt schon ziemlich gut, wenn man
halt jetzt nicht das OP Gear,
also Schmuckzeug hat.
Ich meine das Upgrade
habe ich riesig
gemerkt, jetzt mit dem neuen Schmuck.
Ja. Ist doch nicht schlecht
für einen Anfänger. Das Asula Set
ist mega nice.
Macht doch gar keinen Sinn dann hier für
Pre-Duo-Witches zu gehen.
Was ich halt machen würde, das
ich würde halt echt
schon dann also das
Asula Set tragen und dann nacheinander
für die Bisse-Items halt eben gehen.
Und erstmal nur den Faux, weil durch das
Schmuckseck kannst du wirklich viel besser auf
Zarka, Danda und Co
fokussen und
musst den ja erst Pre-Witches und so was
machen. Ist schon ganz nice.
Und die sind ja mit den Patches auch
relativ schnell. Also es gibt ja viel, das ist ja
nicht wie ein Dark oder so, wo dann
ein A-Patch kommt und gefühlt
drei Vierteljahr später hier in EU.
Ja.
Ja gut, wir sind schon ganz schön
hinterher jetzt mittlerweile wieder.
Echt, weil du hast mir doch mal gesagt vor einer
Weile, so irgendwie hier Korea
Patches und irgendwie zwei Wochen später warst du dann am Start.
Ja, das ist so. Wenn irgendwelche Class
Änderungen sind, dann haben wir meistens
Ach so, stimmt, Content.
Die ganz neuen Skills sind, haben wir meistens diese
10-Milli-Änderungen.
Dann haben wir dann nichts die Woche später drauf.
Ja, stimmt, Content.
Content hast du ja an Kamaself gesehen.
So, das ist ewig gedauert.
Ich weiß nicht, wie drei Vierteljahre
oder so. Das war ja ewig.
Genau. Und in Korea
ist ja jetzt auch schon die neue
Rahn raus, also die neue Klasse.
Und die ganzen Skills,
die Chars kriegen ja
Fusion Skills und
die Rabam Skills,
also sprich, du machst
aus eben zwei Skills
ein.
Und dann kriegst du halt noch mehr
Damage auf den alten Spells, wie jetzt
zum Beispiel beim Wizard. Obwohl ich mir das letzte
Mal, wo ich mir die Damage Sachen bei
Witch angeguckt hab, war eigentlich kaum ein Unterschied
zu sehen.
Ist schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, da bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf,
wie sie das machen für den alten Spells.
Karte mit Ranger ist krass, ist richtig pervers. Ranger wird so
die krasse PvE Maschine.
Kann das Ranger Grill mit Penn Gear
im BDO Stream vielleicht auch mal ein paar Pirates
killen?
Was?
Ich dachte, dann kann das Ranger Grill im Stream mit Penn Gear
auch mal ein paar Pirates killen.
Ach so, ja. Wenn es
OP ist dann. Alter, die flamen
alle den Stream so richtig krass, aber es ist
auch rechtfertig. Der ist so scheiße,
der auf dem BDO Stream. Dafür ist das
Ranger Grill hot.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau, wie die
ausgeschaut hat. Ich weiß nur, dass das Ranger
Grill nicht schlecht fand.
Du fandst es geil, aber ich fand
es nicht. Ich kann mich schon gerne mal dran erinnern. Ich weiß nicht,
ob die war nicht schlecht.
Cosplay Grills.
Genau, die Cosplay
Grills.
Bei mir schreibt gerade einer was
zu Xbox.
Verfolgt die Xbox One-Side-Release.
Man muss sagen, es geht langsam wieder Richtung
bergauf. Was aber nicht unbedingt
schwer war nach diesem Katastrophen-Release.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ich war richtig
gehypt. Ich bin früher morgen
losgefahren und habe halt die
Xbox gesniped.
Im Marktplatz.
Und? War bestimmt einfach, wollte sonst keiner.
Nee, da standen
noch
10 andere Plebs da und es waren nicht so viele da.
Aber ich habe das Beating gewonnen.
Aber ich hatte auch Pre-Order drauf. Ich habe vorher
angerufen. Bis die abholen.
Und danach hast du festgestellt,
es sackt.
Am Anfang dachte ich mir,
nice, nice, nice. Der Teufel
lag dann im Detail.
Aber das erste Menü auf der X-Bauen
ist so grausam. Ja, das war richtig Krebs.
Das hatte ich schon Playstation 3-Niveau.
Schlechter.
Oder schlechter.
Schlechter als Playstation 3.
Das mussten sie erst mal schaffen.
Die 360 hat absolut Maßstäbe
gesetzt, was das anbelangt. Und man schafft
es mit der nächsten Konsole, es schlechter
zu machen als bei der 10-Jahre, naja
8 Jahre alten.
Weiß nicht,
was sieht sich da...
Aber weiß es nicht.
Microsoft Lull.
Microsoft
lullrott. Wo sie uns dann erzielt haben
nach dem Motto oh du kannst jetzt so toll dein
Fernseher anschließen undiin krasser Baseball-
ergebnisse drauf angucken. Ich weiß jetzt,
das ist mir so scheißegal. Vor allem ging das ja nicht
den Mandien. In Deutsch? Ja stimmt,
stimmt.
Zumal mich halt Baseball-Ergebnisse auch so
voll krass interessieren, ja.
Was meinst du von Baseball keinen Damen hat?
Halt die Fresse.
Ich wollte gerade
sagen, es mattert nicht.
Er ist voll bädertlich
Man darf nämlich nur zu Dingen was sagen, wo man sich top auskennt
Und selbst dann kommen die leute sagen du bist keine ahnung
Oh, ich habe ja noch ein hilf auf ich habe ja alles irgendwie
Ich muss mal zum pferd na, wobei kann ich auch enden der runde machen
Ich habe nicht immer das not hier
War es geupgraded? Nee gar nicht immer verbunden. Ich ornert. Ich bin aber auch loop was so was angeht
Warum bewegt sich die katze nicht?
Das ist jetzt die richtige Frage. Not sure if troll
Weil es ein foto ist und weil das foto sieht halt so real aus
Ja und so das sieht man nicht dass es ein foto sieht aus wie live stream
Aber das ist hast du mal bei mir reingeguckt das bild von der katze
Das sieht so richtig dramatisch aus dieses bild mit dem schwarzen hintergrund
Und wie sie da guckt hat sich gerade bewegt
Da würde ich mir Gedanken machen wenn die sich bewegt hat bei dir
Weißt du noch wo beim stream immer dieser link in war wo dann geklopft wurde
Dieses gift da wo man wo dann links und rechts im kopf höher als und klopfen war
Nee sagt mir gar nichts jetzt. Kennst du das nee wurdest du damit nie getrollt
Ach du meinst dass du dass du gedacht hast es klopft eine an der tür
Ja genau das habe ich das ich habe das ein paar mal gehört ja aber so dass es jetzt das ultra
Das war mal richtig im hype da hast du alle fünf minuten diesen scheiß gekriegt da im twitch chat
Das weiß ich nach
Nee das habe ich nie so richtig mitgekriegt also ich kenne das jetzt wo du sagst habe ich das
Paar mal schon mitgekriegt aber wusste nicht dass das jetzt hier so rum gemimt wurde damit
Oh ja ich glaube das vor zwei jahren oder so anderthalb jahren war das echt
War das ein mehmer ja ein mehmer richtig ist ein mehmer
Ich fasse es nicht dass schulz keine ne schulz ich habe jetzt habe ich auf s easy s krass man sind
Eine richtige pv la gang weiß noch wie wir früher wir früher in dark uns über die die casual pv m
Crinder in df und so lustig gemacht haben aber gut wir haben ja noch ein progress gemacht
Wobei es gab es gar nicht mehr wie man in dark überhaupt geld gemacht hat man hat sich alles
Selber auf haben die f siegel war eine sache was was gab die fg ist siegel sachen zerlegen oder
Aber boss sachen farben und und zellen ja genau ich habe mich immer beim karsten durch
Geschnurrt im karsten habe ich tafel auf atlantis gemacht geklitscht übelst abgeklitscht
Kammerbett voll drei kleris bester mob namen aus dauerung runi hura was auch immer sie sich
Dabei gedacht haben wir diesem namen runi hura klingt da nice der gerüstung acht platin verkauft
Immer voll ab war geil acht platin hat dafür mehr gekostet irgendwie habe ich acht platin im kopf
Echt ich habe wolkenlied gefahren das kommt man auch schön mit stadt pull das weiß ich noch die
Leute denken jetzt auch was haben sie wieder reden sie wieder vom griech
Die alten leute war es doch da haben sie sich über die schon 20 jahre gespielt hat
Was wollen die dann oder sind halt so in dark zu die normalsten begriffe überhaupt gewesen
So außerhalb denken wir zu was ist hier los aber ein vorteil hat es dadurch dass wir so
lang dauert gespielt haben diese grundbegriffe und sachen in mmos die sind halt heute teilweise
Es ist immer noch so ja du weißt du weißt du gut dann und so was in der richtung so
grundlegende mechaniken und vor allem bezeichnung ist in jedem also damit lustig
Na es fangen wir meine mmos in ja nicht schon ewig draußen aber weit bei bdo habe ich mir
schon das gefühlt dass der ganz viele neu angefangen haben glaube ich auch am anfang
vom spiel habe ich halt immer irgendwas geklärt erklärt in meinem englisch und
habe halt immer mmo begriffe genommen da hieß es dann immer so und jetzt noch mal in
deutsch bitte und ich habe dann händeringend irgendwie versucht das irgendwie anders zu
erklären ich glaube mmo ich glaube mmos war halt so wie er war es so veteran mäßig so
die leute die als so schon zu dauern teilweise er war krass zeiten gespielt
haben dann kam ein riesen neuer schwung mit wo allerdings wo ist halt auch genau wo ist
das erste und beste oder überhaupt und selbst davon sind ja viele jetzt ist ja auch schon
alt ja und ich glaube bdo ist so ein game was auch